yes please uh representative John Hunt
present I am here and I'm by
myself okay representative John
pusk representative John
Hunt now I can hear you you're repeating
is that some sorry that's me um okay uh
so pusk said he might be late so okay I
I'll watch for him representative Jason
Osborne uh Keith Ammon that's me Here
and Now by
myself representative Max
Abramson hereby
myself representative Bonnie
ham representative
Ham's here representative Joseph to PMA
here and
alone representative Jeffrey
grion representative
gon I don't see him representative Don
Johnson here and alone but I do have two
teenage daughters who will probably be
running in and out behind me at some
point because they're home without
anything to
do okay but they're not in the room with
me now they're up in their
rooms representative Paul Terry
president
alone representative Christy
Bartlett I in my
room representative Richard Abel
representative Abel I am at home uh I'm
alone in the room my wife is elsewhere
in the
house okay representative Chris Herbert
I'm here I'm alone except my wife is in
the house uh working from
home representative Connie van hton
present and I'm
alone okay representative Tina
Fargo I'm here I'm alone in the room my
husband is in another part of the
house all right representative Joyce
Weston I'm here I'm alone in my office
there is somebody else in the
house okay representative Jane
Balo I'm here I'm home alone but my
daughter may be in and out later
on okay representative Anita Bros I am
here I'm alone in the room my husband's
in the house and there are way too many
animals in the house as
well all right and last uh but not least
representative Chris
melar representative Ammon I amend my
presence to note that my wife is also
present in the house thank you okay
thank you that's it okay Jeff gson just
join us so yes thank you Mr
chairman okay
and okay all right so I guess we'll open
up the public hearing and
hp62 so Bill I'm going
to uh promote you to a panelist so you
can so we can see your smiling
face
okay and I see John P has
arrived uh thank you m Mr chairman and
members of the Commerce Committee it's a
pleasure to be with you today it's
refreshing compared to being with my
committee U this this morning I am uh
for the record I'm representative
William Marsh representing seven towns
in southern Carol County relevant to
House Bill 62 I also chair the New
Hampshire rare disease advisory
Council and I'm pleased to offer for
your consideration today House Bill 62
relative to continued in network access
to certain Health Care
Providers this bill began with a concern
brought to the rare disease advisory
Council last spring
briefly since rare disease patients have
diseases about which few doctors have
any expertise or experience they
frequently choose their insurance
products based on whether that product
allows access to the particular Doctor
Who may have expertise in their
particular rare disease when panels are
narrowed they may lose access to the
doctor they believed would have they
would have had access to when they
purchased their insurance
product consequently they are left
paying for a product which they believe
provides little or no value to
them the language of this bill is based
on Georgia Senate Bill 352 which passed
the Georgia Senate last year simply if
an insurer Prov if an insurer includes a
provider in its published directory
which a prospective insured used in
selecting their health plan then the
insurer must maintain ACC access to that
provider until the renewal date
exceptions are made if a provider loses
their license or unilaterally terminates
participation in my mind this is simply
a truth and advertising issue insurers
would never be subject to this provision
if they did not publish directories
which effectively promised perspective
Insurance access to particular
providers Tyler Brandon advised me that
modification of RSA 420 j7d would
require an update to the contract
provision in RSA 420 j8 I did email you
all Amendment
0067 last week and that would accomplish
uh that revision as well um thank you
and with that I'm willing to take
questions okay great thank you hey Chris
uh when you sit up maybe it's best to
just turn your camera off before you do
that okay
all right uh let's see are there any
questions for representative
Marsh okay guess it's pretty
straightforward Bill thank you so next
uh uh so I guess we're all set thank you
much and you can certainly stay on uh
and and watch while we I'll stay for the
next bill oh that's right that's right
okay so next I have is Heidi croll so
Heidi would you raise your hand and then
I will upgrade you to a
panelist there you are and you bump up
and promote to
panelist
and okay you're on
Heidi um can you hear me in okay Mr
chairman everything's good good all
right great um good morning uh Mr
chairman and members of the committee um
it's good to see everybody and uh thank
you for having me uh my name is Heidi
croll I work at Gallagher cahan gartrell
and I'm here today representing um ahip
which is America's health insurance
plans um we are the uh National trade
Association for um the health insurance
carriers um and obviously have a number
of members here in New Hampshire um ahip
respectfully uh opposes um House Bill 62
uh for a number of reasons and I know
others will be testifying uh about this
as well um the first thing I wanted to
say I think is that um the providers do
quite a bit of work um maintaining their
provider directories uh they're updated
uh very regularly um and in addition uh
it's something that the department keeps
a close eye on um I know that they can
be this provider directories can be
included in um uh Market conduct exams
and uh you know there's improve ments
are uh required and um the carriers um
carry out those improvements so um we
wanted to mention that uh as the 60-day
provision which was just mentioned by um
representative Marsh um that is an
important provision in there in law um
to protect consumers um to ensure that
if their uh provider has left the
network for whatever reason um that the
consumer um is able to continue using
that provider for for 60 days um as if
the provider had not left the network um
so there are continuity of care um
provisions and protections in current
law um the other thing um we are
concerned about with this bill is that
it undermines the value of Provider
networks so carriers um you know spend a
lot of time uh uh developing their
networks and carefully selecting
providers based on um provids um
credentialing um quality of service
patient safety um those sorts of things
to really ensure that um the providers
that they have included uh in their
networks are um of you know the utmost
quality uh you know in terms of
providing high quality and Affordable
Services uh the other concern that we
have with the bill um is that there
would be no protection for the patient
in terms of balance billing
um you may recall a couple years ago we
had a house bill
1809 um that bill only applies to
anesthesiology uh Radiology emergency
medicine and pathology um so uh any of
other providers who are out of network
um under this bill would still be free
to balance Bill the patient um so
there's language in here about ensuring
um I think basically that the um
the covered person is you know kind of
kept whole and so I don't think that
there's really any way that um uh you
know we we can have that sort of uh
Insurance um so that in a nutshell um
those are the reasons um that we are
opposed to um House Bill 62 and we would
uh respectfully request that you find um
this bill to be uh inexpedient to
legislate and I'd be happy to try to
answer any questions or if I'm not able
to um other speakers may be able to or
we can certainly take it back with the
carriers and get back to you with
answers okay uh we do have a question uh
represent burough has a
question um thank you for taking my my
question um back to I I I assume you
were on When U representative Marsh was
speaking and how would you respond to um
his concern that a patient for example
who has a rare disease who signed on to
a network maybe specific speically for
the purpose of having access to a rare
disease specialist um and then that
person they they suddenly may be cut off
from that How would how does the
insurance uh industry respond to that
concern um sure and there there maybe
other carriers who can amplify on this
but I think generally speaking um first
of all there are network adequacy
requirements um that the carriers are
required to meet or exceed um so you
know I think that they're there might
not be that specific provider um the
person's name um still in the network
but there could be um other providers
who provide the same Services um and
obviously um are meeting high quality
standards as well um the other thing I
will say is that there um are Provisions
for care for patients to receive care um
by out of network providers so um if
that P if that patient um really felt
strongly about um uh continuing to be a
patient with that provider um they would
have the ability to do so thank
you um representative Abramson has a
question thank you Mr chair um and thank
you for taking my question my the
question I was trying to raise my hand
for uh under William Marsh but maybe you
can answer um is is there an estimate on
how much this would increase insurance
premiums if the bill passed
um I don't have an estimate but we
certainly do believe that that there
could be upward pressure on
premiums um and I would add that the um
I believe that the insurance department
will probably be testifying um before
you today um it's my understanding that
um requests can be made of the insurance
department um anytime there's kind of a
you know a new mandate type of Bill
that's being considered um that they
have the um ability upon request um to
uh do an analysis to try to understand
um the impacts so that could be
something that um the insurance
department could potentially take a look
at followup for the question me
inquire um is there a way to amend this
bill so that hypothetically if you had a
service provider and they're originally
charging uh a certain cost for services
if they were to try to increase what
they build the insurance company uh at
at too great an increase in a year that
there would there would be some kind of
Outlet in place under the bill to uh
allow the insurance carrier to
essentially say
no in other words if they increase their
price by you know 177% in one year
without a without an
explanation well I think I I'm not um a
Contracting expert by any stretch of the
imagination but you know at a high level
um I believe believe that um you know
when the carriers enter into a contract
with a provider or hospital or provider
group um that that is a typically a
one-year contract so during that that
contract period I don't think that there
would be um any changes uh in terms of
what the provider um is billing or what
the carrier is
reimbursing um from year to year those
can be adjusted um and certainly if um a
carrier and a provider uh at the end of
at the end of one contract when
negotiations are going on for the next
contract if the two parties are not able
to come to an agreement um then there
would be no contract and that provider
would um would not be in the
network okay any other questions for
attorney croll seeing none thank you
very much thank you Mr chairman and I
guess I'll get you Tyler brenon
next so there you are thank
you
[Music]
and are you on Tyler there you yes and
you can hear me and see me okay I could
see my little screen but still had to
click that pieces so thank you uh Tyler
Brandon with the New Hampshire insurance
department I'm the director of Health
economics and uh we do not have a
position on the bill which uh as most of
you know is traditional um I'm going to
speak to both the bill and the amendment
uh because I think the amendment
potentially provides a little bit of
clarification on some of the questions
that came up um clearly there's the
intention to protect the member so the
member doesn't pay more than cost
sharing when they go to a healthcare
provider that is no longer in the
network but traditionally if the
healthare provider is outside of the
network then they can charge the patient
whatever they want because there is no
agreement with the insurer to accept
anything
less one of the ways we govern the
relationship between a carrier and a
health care provider is a section of the
insurance statute called provider
contract standards and within that
existing provider contract standards
there is the continued access provision
so every contract with a healthc care
provider needs to include language that
says a member or patient can continue to
access that health care provider under
the arrangement that uh existed prior to
the termination of the contract but it's
just for 60 days so um the amendment
changes that provision and then links
the original Bill and says the member of
the patient would have continued access
for as long as they are under that that
contract their that subscriber
certificate in other words their health
insurance benefit agreement which goes
back to I think that the purpose of the
bill which is if you've selected a
carrier based on the network you've got
kind of that ongoing
access um we have experienced some
confusion about uh how this would
operationalize in the past um there is a
requirement also for members to be
notified about a provider that is
leaving the network um when some of
these situations exist the um there are
questions sometimes about the patient
liability ability at least in theory the
patient would be um protected that being
said Network development is is
constantly kind of an evolving thing and
when you think about the cycle that most
employers or subscribers operate on to
the extent they're choosing their
insurance and many of them do it for a
calendar year plan year but not all of
them so if you're choosing in the fall
your insurance starts in January um and
goes through the calendar year on the
group side it may not be synchronized
with the calendar year so to try and
align kind of the network devel El the
Contracting phase with that of the uh of
the people buying their insurance would
be a substantial Challenge and um
probably not something that could be
operationalized very easily um even
trying to make those adjustments deals
with sort of cost shearing accumulators
a lot of other operational challenges
and even when you think about the
budgets of of hospitals carriers
employers they're all not going to be
lined up and that's what lends itself in
part to this kind of Disconnect and the
challenge of um synchronizing things in
such a way that uh everybody chooses
their Network and the network doesn't
change and you have that continued
access um we will say that any change in
legislatively that does give the
providers more bargaining power you are
likely to see some inflationary pressure
with claims simply if they have more
power they can demand more um I was
unaware that this kind of originated
with some of the rare disease concerns
we tend to think of providers such as
hospitals having the most bargaining
power it's very difficult to sell
insurance without one of our major
hospitals in the network but that being
said The more a provider has kind of a
lock on a particular service they're
more likely to act as a monopoly so
that's certainly a consideration but at
the same time if you think about kind of
continued access under the contract
terms that were in place a year ago that
could be detrimental to a provider too a
provider that has accepted a fixed
payment at a certain level and now the
underlying health care cost cost of
treating somebody with a particular
condition goes up the provider wants to
get more out of it they can't live under
the existing contract and now the member
or the patient has continued access at
those those lower reimbursement levels
so with a provider that's paid a percent
of charges they could just increase
their charges but I think it's going to
potentially hit providers a little bit
unequally um the insurance department is
positioned to do what we call a mandate
review we refer to Insurance mandates in
the traditional way in other words it
changes the scope of services that are
covered but the way our statute is
actually written it gives the department
and the chair of a committee like this
the flexibility to look at something
that could be considered a mandate that
actually is more than just the change in
the scope of services so the department
would be able to do an analysis um of
the policy and the claims data to
provide some estimate about how this
might impact premiums but it does take
us we tend to want to allow about six
weeks to do the work and it can cost
about 25,000 to the department that
being said we do have the contract in
place and uh would' be happy to do the
work for the committee um if there's
enough interest in doing
that great we have questions uh
representative Herbert you're up
first Chris yeah
yeah you g to
unmute okay the General thanks thank
yous for being here
um is this a I'm a little uh unsure
about these people are Specialists that
are rare I mean is I'm trying to figure
out do they have do they charge more
because of their
expertise uh totally or um is it a is it
a situation where uh if they or are they
just really busy because they're the
only people that do this work and uh
they don't need any more business and
and they you know raise their price if
they can uh or is it a situ and if it is
that kind of a situ if it is a situation
where it's just their specialty and
they're not that busy can't can
insurance companies share these these uh
providers I mean uh so that they
have uh you know have good business in
in the sense of you know being busy uh
as opposed to just somebody who's
charging a premium because they have a a
specialty I don't know if that made any
sense but I'm just trying to figure out
a way to to get around all these
issues yeah so I think that uh and I'll
speak generally because I can't speak
specifically to some of the issues that
may have come up in the rare disease
Council but uh generally speaking you
are seeing fewer location um in
healthcare in the delivery system that
are performing very specialized services
and that's in part because medicine is
becoming more complicated but it's also
becoming more expensive to set up a
basically a program or an initiative at
a particular setting so you might see
Dartmouth Hitchcock with a providing a
number of services in Lebanon that
aren't offered elsewhere in the state um
the alternative is going to Boston in
the future there may be fewer of those
sites generally speaking professionals
Physicians are paid according to a kind
of a a fee schedule and it's often based
off what Medicare would do so it might
be 200% Medicare um those Physicians
might be independent they might be
represented by a hospital the hospital
on the other hand could be paid at a
substantially higher rate so to the
extent you start to see monopolies
develop they're probably going to take
place both with consideration for the
hospital and the actual physician or
other providers that are involved so I
think to the extent there is recognition
that there may be value or there is
value in certain access to specialized
services in the future we will see fewer
sites
with potentially stronger monopolies
when we developed the Network adequacy
rule we developed uh requirements for a
number of services you should get at the
local level those things are primary
care those things are physical therapy
mental health type services but for very
specialized Services the best we could
really do is say look those Services
need to be accessible within New England
we simply don't have enough providers
that we could create a standard that
would be local enough without creating a
monopoly and that provider saying car
you have to contract with me at whatever
rates I demand so that's maybe a more
General answer than than what you were
looking for but it is reflective of the
trends where are
seeing thank
you representative
AEL
yes thank you uh Mr Brandon it's good to
see you again and thank you for your
testimony um I'm trying to to grasp the
maximum uh time period that an insurance
company if this if this if this bill uh
goes through uh that the an insurance
company would have to continue to
pay uh The Specialist uh and um I think
Miss croll said that that there's a
60-day uh already written in there's a
60-day period so that means if
this all happened on the first day of
coverage there would be 10 months as a
maximum that would
continue um is that correct uh oh I see
you're if I understand your question
you're talking about an additional 10
months so right so a maximum you choose
your insurance in November December your
insurance starts on January but as soon
as you've choose chosen your insurance
then there's a dispute with the provider
they're out a Network um today you
should have continued AC for January and
February under the the the the bill with
the amendment then you're in a situation
where your insurance runs through
December so you presumably would have
continued access to that provider
throughout the calendar year and um so
that would be a big change for sure um
May I follow up please is a question may
inquire yes so so that if the if we do
not pass this bill then um
the uh the insured would have would have
a maximum 10 month period to pay which
that person would have to pay extra uh
under the current under the current
situation no so not necessarily so the
the idea with that continued access is
that gives the carrier and the member a
chance to find Rider um rather than
facing a cliff where they no longer have
access or as you were suggesting have to
pay the added net Arrangement and and
there that goes back to network adequacy
requirements there has to be access
somewhere for those services that are
covered under your plan is benefit
design but it might mean moving from uh
if a insurer didn't want to contract
with dmouth Hitchcock to a provider in
Boston something like that um that being
said we are talking about relatively
rare scenarios that it would be um at
that level I think it's might be a more
specific situation um but again that
continued access is to to create a
transition
period Well Set uh representative
Bartlett thank you um it's nice to see
you Mr Brandon again um okay
so this isn't just necessarily going to
apply to individually paid insurance
contract is that correct right it's not
specific to the individual or the group
market so um I mean we've been using
individuals because it's easiest to
follow but presumably you could have a
group renewing in the middle of the
calendar year and uh facing the same
kind of situation where they've selected
a um a carrier based on the the the
network that's there and uh um but then
there's a dispute in the contract and
they would have presumably they should
have continued access with the bill and
the amendment to that provider but um
right yes further question me inquire
thank you um so that if um an
employee really is not involved in
negotiating an insurance contract and
they say there's a three-year
term um this would extend more than just
the 10 months we're talking about it
could extend for the life of the
contract between the employer and the
insurance company is that correct no the
way we would interpret the the language
it's based on the really the plan year
so to the extent that an employer has
signed up for their insurance um they
may be intending to stay with the
carrier for the next three years but
every year the the rates are are set
just in place for a year and that's when
that the plan year would would take
place further question thank you um but
the employee is probably not involved in
those negotiations is so they I mean
they could really be stuck couldn't they
if they so it's yeah it's an interesting
you know you raised actually a larger
question that I hope I don't be seen as
digressing from but individuals tend to
be quite selective about their insurance
products that's why you you might see
more often narrow networks in the idual
Market whereas in the group Market an
employer tries to represent all
employees you T fewer examples of narrow
networks in the group Market I'm
speaking nationally as much as locally
and in part because of the the scenario
you're describing the individual
employee doesn't have a lot of of weight
in the selection of the carrier and the
product so the employer tends to a on
the side of having broader networks
richer benefit designs and um uh and of
course in the you know the small group
Market there are a lot of sort of Market
rules and large group seen as those
employers being able to look after their
employees and choose benefit designs
with a fair amount of
sophistication thank
you okay um before you go Tyler make
sure I understand um in the bill there's
an um exemptions or providers that it
doesn't include and not withstanding
this is not first of all this doesn't
look like it's just narrowed to a
specialist this looks like all providers
is that correct yeah that's that's an
important point and and I should have
made that we're not talking about just
rare diseases and really we're not even
talking about providers just in New
Hampshire so you're literally talking
about a contract change with what would
be thousands of providers in a network
so it it's uh I can't understate kind of
the significance that um this could have
okay but on the other side it then when
this exemption says except if uh becomes
the provider becomes out of network due
to suspension
expiration now don't generally when an
insurance company decides to uh say that
they want to take a provider out of the
network don't they generally wait till
their contract has
expired um there are two scenarios and
um many of the contracts are what are
considered Evergreens they will
automatically renew and those are with
Physicians more likely than hospitals
and um the hospital contracts I me
multi-year contracts with Provisions but
um to the extent that there an
expiration date that does force a
negotiation uh more readily for
sure okay seems this bill would need a
lot of work if we were to try to pass it
okay is there any other uh questions for
Mr Brennan seeing none we thank you very
much for your
testimony excuse me Mr chairman I just
want to let you representative ham has
um joined us by phone and she's out in
the attendee list so she may um raise
her hand using the star n feature on her
phone can can I move her over I could
not move her over I was given the option
of allowing her to speak or removing her
from the meeting entirely and I didn't
want to do that do that uh right but she
can hear just fine from where she is and
if she ra you know knows how to raise
her hand with the star nine she'll be
able to participate okay
so I I did I just clicked her to allowed
her to talk yeah oh okay so I guess can
I just note that representative melier
is now present and also he's I did see
he pops up too so um okay
great uh so that's it for people who
want to
testify um we have quite a list of
people who signed up I guess this is the
the feature benefits of the of having
the electronic sign up um so let's see
we have uh a Carol Crawford uh elected
official is the legislator I assume uh
in support of the bill uh representative
John McDonald is also in support of the
bill uh uh Senator is Cindy roswall um
she uh is in support of the bill uh
Jason Hart uh is opposed to the bill and
uh Lindsay Nido she is opposed to the
bill Lacy Colligan is a member of the
public and supports the Bill uh Paula
manahan from the hospital Association
support of the bill Holly Stevens from
new Futures is uh in support of the bill
uh Statia Nichols uh as a member of the
public and supports the bill uh Joan uh
p p um representing the Hampshire
Association of insurance agents supports
the bill uh Karen privy uh as a member
of the public supports the bill uh
Deborah Reagan coffen a member of the
public supports the bill Eric
rathen also of the public supports the
bill and finally Sabrina Dunlap uh who
represents Anthem is opposed to the bill
and I see that Sabrina Dunlap on that
note has raised her hand out in the
attendees along
okay okay so Sabrina uh and Peter bragon
okay um I think Peter did tell me ahead
of time that he might have a problem but
I'll start with Sabrina first and um so
Sabrina I'm going to promote you to
panelists so you can I assume you want
to
testify there she is hello there thanks
for bringing me over hi everyone I'm
Sabrina Dunlap I'm director of
government relations at Anthem um thanks
for having me I won't repeat everything
that Heidi said but we do um does oppose
this bill and we agree largely with um
many of the concerns Heidi already
raised I do want to just emphasize that
as has been mentioned um the insurance
rigs do require access to out of network
care if it can't be obtained in network
so I think that does get at the
underline concern um with this bill so
happy to take any questions but um I
also did submit written testimony um on
this so thank you
great uh I don't see any question
questions so you're all set there okay
so uh uh Peter bragon you also would
like to
testify Peter you there oh there you go
can you hear me yep okay good sorry uh
thank you Mr chairman and uh I hadn't
mentioned anything earlier um but I
mistakenly was out shoveling snow and
real didn't realize I came in too late
to make the 30 minute window so I
apologize for that thank you for your
Indulgence um thank you Mr chairman uh
for the record Peter bragon representing
Harvard Pilgrim Healthcare the state's
only not for profit Health insurer a
company founded by doctors providing
coverage for over 100,000 of our friends
and Neighbors in the granite state and
we are opposed to House Bill
62 um it reports to protect consumers by
allowing up to one year of what is for
all intents and purposes um in network
access even though the provider has left
the network as had been stated current
law um provides that covered members of
our insurance plans can retain what is
essentially in network access to a
provider for 60 days after the
provider's contract with us ends in
order to allow appropriate transition of
care uh this would be a good place to
point out that in in some instances we
cover access those longer than 60 days
in specific instances and I think the
whole um purpose of this bill came about
because of a specific instance that came
about and we oftentimes will consider
specific circumstances uh for example
the case of a terminal patient we don't
want to force that patient to transition
to another provider so we can work
around that the law says the law does
not say it has to be 60 days but it
certainly has a floor of 60 days we're
willing to work with people to to take
care of that the proposal before you
because of the amendment would replace
the 60-day guaranteed consumer
protection
with a variable scheme that could be
anywhere from zero days to 365 days
given some of the timing issues so in
some cases it gives consumers even less
protection than they already have uh in
addition to less consumer protection as
Tyler mentioned the bill will be very
difficult to implement keeping track of
a data member en roles and who was on
the directory at the time perhaps this
bill would be worthy of consideration if
all of our health plans ran from January
1st to December 31st and all of our
provider contracts ran from January 1st
to December 31st but that's not the way
it works we have plans that start on
every just about every single month in
the calendar and we have provider
contracts that also have a wide array of
starting and ending dates so we believe
hp62 would be unworkable in this uh
environment so we prefer the consumer
protection that exists in current law
it's easy to understand it's easy to
implement and rather than change the
whole system for some is Rel ated uh
incidents we urge you to find hb6
expedience legis thank you very
much okay is there uh representative
aberson has a question if you're willing
to take one I
am go ahead thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question um what are
some of the reasons that uh providers uh
leave the network are they leaving on
their own are they being forced out or
is a mutual agreement I think in most
cases and I'm so no expert but most
cases the contracts just come to an end
and the the negotiations about uh uh
reimbursement rates for various things
lead to one side or the other not uh not
being
cont all
right great all right um seeing Oh
seeing no more questions uh I will close
the public hearing on um House Bill
62 and we have a two-minute
break I got to go find my coffee
oh before you run off just wanted to let
you know I got my vaccine yesterday so I
will be here all day all right you got
it early because of the snowstorm huh
that's right state did a great job
called us right at home on Sunday
night that's that is good but my arm
hurts it's a small place price to pay
yes that's for sure and that but that's
just your first one that's the second
one that's supposed to be more painful
but see what happens I'll risk it
well we haven't been able to sign up for
the second one yet yeah all right I
gotta go find my coffee just a
second I do with
it well good morning all I'm sorry I had
to be late um I had 14 in of fluff out
in the uh the ride driveway I had to
play with and uh it was heavy but it was
nice to
see
so I'm back oh by the way Chris I got
the big
notebook hang on I'll show
you there it
is
and everything is
tabed yeah but the problem is you're not
sitting next to me
anymore well well we have to move the
windows I guess
so well hopefully someday in the near
future we'll be we'll be sitting back in
the
room now good Lord willing
hey March
10th that's my
day how you feeling
Christie you got your shot right how you
feeling just fine my my arm's a little
sore but that's the only thing yeah i'
I've heard from folks that we older
people take it much better because we've
had so much other stuff in our body
already and the Young Folks could be the
Young Folks get it hard because they
haven't had all the stuff that we've had
well we we got most of the diseases we
didn't get all the vaccines so I don't
want this disease yeah I
agree I remember measles being very very
sick with measles I was the first in the
neighborhood to get it yeah back when I
was like four or five I had
diptheria oh yeah it was pretty heavy
yeah but uh then you know all they
started coming out with all the shots
then again when I was years old it was
way back in
1952 right right well I remember you
know I had Ms and German Measles and
measles and you know all of those
chickenpox now we got Z floating
around all right I'm gonna
mute
I just did it I muted myself okay so
we'll open up the public hearing on 191
and here from representative Marsh good
morning representative Marsh hello again
everyone uh for the record I'm
representative William Marsh
representing seven towns in southern
Caroll County relevant to this bill I
I've been a trustee of Huggins Hospital
since 2004 including two non-consecutive
terms as corporate treasur and I'm
retired from my solo Private Practice
I'm pleased today to offer for your
consideration house spill 191 relative
to Prior authorizations and patient
transfers under the Managed Care Group
Health insurance policies which I found
at the request of the New Hampshire
Hospital
Association first of all this is not a
bill to ban prior
authorizations it does three things
first it requires 60 days notice for new
prior authorization requirements doctors
and hospitals need this tracking
patients who have already been referred
for a treatment or consultation is
obviously burdensome and it takes time
to educate employed practitioners about
new requirements so that they can
comply second the bill requires that
prior authorizations remain valid for 6
months sometimes it takes that long to
schedule a surgery or get an appointment
to see a busy
specialist third last and for me this is
the most important section of the bill
it limits the use of Prior
authorizations to delay the transfer of
patients to step down
facilities we all want patients to get
the appropriate level of
care we all want to not spend too much
money to provide that
care and understand that all of our
hospitals have very narrow operating
margins in a fee for service Hospital
extending the length of Stay by one day
can easily become financially
burdensome in critical access hospitals
this is even more of a problem as one
condition of participation in Medicare
for a critical access hospitals
maintaining an average length of stay of
96 hours or
less hospitals do understand the need to
have appropriate transport for such
transfers but delaying or preventing
transfers to less expensive step down
facilities with prior authorizations is
just not
reasonable Co has hit the balance sheet
of our hospitals particularly hard so
this last provision is particularly
needed right now further the recent
surge of Co strained our total Hospital
capacity delay in sending patients to
step down facilities exacerbates that
problem promptly addressing this issue
will better prepare New Hampshire to
handle potential Surge from the new more
infectious strains of covid that we hear
are
coming I thank you all for consideration
of my bill I'll be glad to take
questions I can't stay for the entire
hearing as I need to return to Health
and Human Services to introduce another
bill any question yeah representative
Abel has a
question yes thank you uh thank you dror
and uh representative Marsh um
does this apply to um to hospital
services and to prescriptions or is it
just one or the
other uh the short answer is yes uh the
third provision the the transfer
provision I don't think applies to
prescriptions that that would strictly
have to do with facilities thank
you okay any other questions
all right see not thank you very much
thank you uh I have quite a list here so
um let's see why don't uh we'll do
another so I see if there's any other
legislator who signed up uh I don't see
that right off the
top um okay so then we're going up
um uh let's see well here's is Matt H is
he Matt are you on the attendee
list do do I see Matt Matt are you there
you he said he was going to testify but
I see him on the
list on on the attendees list oh there
he is okay there we go okay I'm
promoting you and uh he's a former
member of the committee
good
morning attorney Hood how are you
today hopefully he's almost there there
we
go uh thank you Mr chairman I am here I
hope that you can hear me yes I
can great thank you very much and thank
you for the opportunity to testify my
name is Matthew Hood I'm the vice
president of government relations at
Dartmouth Hitchcock
and uh I am here this morning to support
uh House Bill 191 as we believe that it
reduces barriers to necessary Services
I'm I'm going to highlight particular
sections of the new 420 J12 that would
uh particularly alleviate patient as
well as administrative
burdens um section one uh representative
Marsh spoke to this about um scheduling
procedures and having a six Monon uh
window during which the prior
authorization is valid and I guess what
I'd like to say is it's not just a
schedule but oftentimes uh patients need
to reschedule appointments for many
reasons whether it's patient
complications provider illnesses or
schedule shortages of resources uh covid
was mentioned and as people know um that
threw a wrench into um scheduled
procedures last spring uh there was
actually a bill that addressed that
issue and pushed out the authorization
date for um procedures that may have
been affected by the by that period of
time I would reiterate this is not a
blanket prohibition on prior
authorizations but it's it's a request
to not have to start from Ground Zero um
I don't think six months is particularly
honorous um uh but I'm happy to engage
in that
conversation the next piece that I'd
like to speak to is um
when uh patient this is when patients
are undergoing a procedure and the
provider provider can see an otherwise
previously
unknown uh situation that requires
additional treatment oftentimes um that
is that secondary procedure that's done
in the course of the primary procedure
isn't covered because there wasn't a
prior off received for that um this is
one that particularly strikes me as as
odd since why would we ever want to make
a patient go through two procedures um
in the same area so I actually
understand uh Mr chairman and members of
the committee that um ensures the
provider the carriers have some U
concerns with experimental treatments in
this context but I'm fairly certain that
the committee and others could draft
language that would exclude experimental
treatments as part of this uh
provision uh
finally want to make sure it's final um
I would reiterate the interf facility
transport piece since I think again
that's a win-win for both uh providers
and carriers we have a patient who's
been sitting uh at Darth Hitchcock since
March of
2020 um I I I'm not pretending that that
is exclusively the uh result of failure
to get a prior authorization for
discharge there's lots of complicating
factors but that's a bed for almost a
year uh that can't be used and um the
sooner people can uh at at a high Acuity
facility so the the sooner that people
can move the sooner that uh other
additional patients who need treatment
can get in so with that I'll conclude um
happy to answer any questions and
appreciate your
time uh I don't see any hands up so I
guess you're get off easy
today you I should say so thank you
representative
uh all right so now we'll do uh do one
more support um Michael
padmore so Michael if you just raise
your hand and jump to the top for
me there you
are promoting to a
panelist and Bonnie you might want to
mute oh this way you're on the phone do
you know how do you know the phone
commands
Bonnie um no I guess
not
let's see I have them in my notes here
somewhere I think it's star nine is that
what it is to raise your hand and star
six to mute and unmute star six there
you go good morning can you hear me yes
good morning great uh well good good
morning um thank you Mr chairman and
members of the committee uh for the
record my name is Mike padmore and I'm
the director of advocacy with the New
Hampshire Medical Society representing
Physicians across the state um the New
Hampshire Medical Society strongly
supports House Bill 191 uh which aims to
reform the prior authorization process
that private insurance companies have in
place um with respect to time I I'll
keep my remarks brief um as I've
actually worked with a couple of our
physicians um and and different practice
managers who are involved with some of
the different practices around the state
uh who have uh been able to sign up uh
to testify uh this morning and I think
can really speak directly uh to the
impact of prior authorization um better
than I can um so I'll just close by
saying uh that in addition uh to the New
Hampshire Medical Society um five
physician specialty organizations are
also in strong support the New Hampshire
Academy of family physicians American
Academy of Pediatrics uh the New
Hampshire chapter um New Hampshire uh
American College of Obstetricians and
gynecologists uh the New Hampshire
academy uh of Emergency Physicians and
the New Hampshire Orthopedic Society uh
and then finally I'll just refer you to
my written testimony um which outlines
actually just a number of different
physician stories um uh nurse stories
just from a variety of providers and
patients about how prior off has
impacted um patient care um so with that
um we urge you to vote all to pass on
House Bill 191 uh and I'm happy to
answer any questions that you might
have great uh representative Ben Hoon
has a question thank you and thank you
for taking my testimony it's good to see
you back Mr padmore um I have a question
that is probably more basic than it
needs to be but I'd like to understand
why prior authorization is necessary to
move a patient to a lesser level of care
is that I just don't understand that
wouldn't that just be automatic to move
a patient to where he belongs to a
lesser expensive con conceivably um
level of care thank you for your
question and what I'll do forgive me I I
do think there may be some folks um who
are testifying after me who just can
speak to that with much more experienced
than I can so I I'll defer to them and
and and close my testimony but again
happy to answer any additional question
questions thank you I appreciate
that okay all right so now we'll change
your pace a little bit and we'll invite
Heidi crawl up who will uh give us the
other point of
view so hi I don't I think I took you
out so you need to raise your hand again
so I can see you oh there you are I see
you now you don't have to raise your
hand i'm promoting you to a panelist
Heidi
and are you there
uh maybe she stepped out oh right she
did say she had another build she was
testifying on so that must be what where
she is right now okay so uh
um then who else so I will have
uh so okay uh Sabrina
dlap and I know I had you here and there
you are okay promote you back up there
you
go
and
hi again hi again over okay hi Sabrina
Dunlap director of government relations
at
Anthem um I thank you for having me I
did submit written testimony um from our
medical director dick lefur who could
not be here today so I did point out in
our testimony two Provisions in
particular um that I'd like to speak to
one is the procedure during another um
already approved procedure so we
generally do approve uh procedures that
are medically necessary but we do review
them and we think that's really
important for patient safety um and to
make sure that the procedure that was
performed during the other procedure was
in fact medically appropriate so I just
want to flag that um and from from what
I can tell we we actually most of the
time do approve these so um we don't
really see that as as a problem or a
barrier to care at all um and then the
second issue is the transfer issue so
we actually do not require prior off for
transfer um we're aligned with the
providers we would like to get patients
to appropriate care especially step down
care um so we actually don't require
prior o for the transfer we do review
the facility however um and I think
that's important to flag because we want
to make sure patients actually end up in
the correct place um and as far as I
know I've talked to our internal folks
we have very fast turnaround time on uh
transfers so again we don't really see
that as a problem um I we're not seeing
slow turnarounds we're not seeing delays
and certainly prior o is not a barrier
to care or a barrier to being
transferred um I would again emphasize
the importance of patient safety here
and and the importance of reviewing the
facility to make sure patients actually
end up in the right place um so I think
that's it for me I do just want to
emphasize that um you know we see prior
o as a really important Care Management
tool it's an important uh decision
support tool and I do think this bill
undermines prior o in a really
detrimental way and and we do oppose it
obviously um so happy to take any
questions and thank you very much for
your
time any questions from the
committee okay see none thank you very
much uh okay now we'll go let's see uh
Paula minahan from the New Hampshire
Hospital
Association so Paula if you raise your
hand or she might be there she is
okay and good morning
Paula
and she might be in that other
[Laughter]
committee okay oh no no can you hear me
now sorry about that I didn't unmute
properly I I have two zooms going as you
right I guessed so I um had to get on
the right one sorry um good morning Mr
chairman members of the committee my
name is Paula minahan Senior vice
president state government relations
with the New Hampshire Hospital
Association representing all our
hospitals we are in strong support of
hb11 and we do thank representative
Marsh for agreeing to sponsor this bill
a Senate bill Senate Bill 531 was
introduced last year that attempted to
address some of our cons the concerns of
the provider community and while some of
those provisions of the Senate Bill were
passed last year and signed into law to
areas of concern remain and they were
outlined very well by your by
representative Marsh the administrative
complexities associated with the prior o
as well as the transfer
provision we understand that the
insurance carriers utilize prior off and
again we are not saying anything um
we're not asking that that be removed um
I I just want to be very clear all we
are asking is and that when a prior
authorization is necessary the floor
goes from three months to six months and
I think um Senator Hood did a very very
good job explaining giving you some
examples of when that occurs so that is
um all that we're trying to do is ensure
that during especially now um that we
have so many issues with folks getting
into a specialist that the floor go from
three months to six months to ease the
burden for providers and patients the um
and I just want to mention the carriers
have we have had discussions with the
carriers um and they have suggested
creating an electronic prior
process that could address some of these
issues and we would agree I think that
is a a great idea um and we welcome
those um discussions however the need to
reduce administrative burden um of Prior
o um needing to be reauthorized multiple
times for the same service remains um I
just wanted to mention the medical
necessity again Senator Hood outlined
that well um it does happen I I heard
the testimony of um Miss Dunlop um and I
guess I would say that that is um one
carrier um and I don't know um what the
particular experience is with our
hospitals but certainly what I have
heard is that this is a problem and that
obviously that's why we put this bill in
um and then um the last change was just
going from um a 30-day notice to a
60-day notice um a prior bill that we
worked on actually had a much longer um
time frame but we we adjusted that to 60
days the patient transfer is an issue
that is very challenging in fact um the
hospital Association and the foundation
for Healthy Communities actually creates
um yearly a barriers to um discharge we
call it or barriers to people um
receiving the right care and we just
produced a report that just is kind of
Hut off the presses and I will share
that with everyone after um this hearing
but we do do have a significant number
of individuals that are unable to get to
the lower level of care we're not
talking about transferring from an acute
care hospital to Mass General that is
not those emergencies are not the issue
we are trying to get patients as again
representative Marsh um clarified
getting them to a lower level such as
rehab um or a long-term care facility
and we just need to get them moved more
quickly there are carriers that require
prior ations again hence why we put this
in the bill we are not looking to um to
undermine any any work that the carriers
are doing and to make sure that they are
it is a legitimate transfer that's why
with the language is written the way it
is um and we're happy to continue to
work with the carriers we have met
numerous times I just wanted to be on
the record um trying to come up with
language or ask them for additional
language but we need something that
really allow allows the providers the
hospitals in this case to work to get to
the right level of care make sure
they're using the carry the the transfer
vendor that um is appropriate and in
network for the carrier we're fine with
all that we just need them to get we
need help getting them into the right
level of care that really is what we're
trying to do um and like I said I I will
share with everyone the barriers to
discharge report that I think will be
illuminated um it's we have the issue
for a lot of carriers um including
Medicare but that this bill does not
address that we do believe that the
prior authorization um the changes to
the prior authorization process are in
the best interest of patients and will
result in a more costeffective Care by
eliminating inappropriate and
unnecessary barriers we support the bill
ask you to pass it and I'm happy to
answer any questions thank you so
much okay any uh questions you have
represent V hooton has a question thank
you I just want to uh to thank both Miss
Dunlap and Miss minahan for addressing
my question and helping me to understand
better what the issues are thank you
okay no more hands and uh so I have just
uh promoted Rebecca uh Zer
Zer that's very good are you able to
hear me yes we are thank you thank you
sorry I'm sorry I Christy bartett just
raised bomb
here impementation somebody's got
something going on in the
background there um I'm sorry this is
for Miss Miss Dunlap I could not find
the written testimony she said that was
um submitted earlier on behalf of
Anthem okay does anybody else have that
if I could um I sent it to the whole
committee I'm happy to send it to you
directly I did send it last night um
sorry I've missed it but it was written
by um our medical director so I'm happy
to send it out again that' be great okay
thank you thank you thank you okay go
ahead yes thank you thank you for the
opportunity to speak I've met some of
you before I'm the director of breast
Imaging at Dartmouth Hitchcock Medical
Center up here in Lebanon and my
testimony is brief but best related by
an example from a tragic story of how
this requirement for preauth ization can
actually kill and this is a true story
from Pennsylvania not from Dartmouth
thankfully but a typical scenario is a
woman came to a radiology facility she
had a breast lump and she had a
prescription from her doctor for a
diagnostic mamogram which is where
things usually start the prescription
did not include orders for
unanticipated additional testing that
would be required but again you can't
guess what's going to happen The
Physician could not be successfully
contacted for this order for the
additional Imaging and the patient left
because otherwise she would have
uncovered medical expenses in the
thousands of dollars and the medically
appropriate testing to diagnose her lump
as a breast cancer which specifically
would include ultrasound an ultrasound
guided core biopsy was not done so the
patient was told her mamogram was normal
and she was sent home she fell through
the cracks the provider thought
Radiology would pick it up and the
radiologist thought the provider would
pick it up and she now has metastatic
breast cancer and is actually in
hospice so the very Act of having to
stop and call someone like a referring
provider or an insurance company when
dealing with women afraid of having
breast cancer stressful potentially
life-threatening is in my opinion as a
As a caretaker inhumane it's inefficient
regularly and it's potentially dangerous
so neither the insurance company nor the
referring provider have any training or
knowledge of breast cancer or Imaging
findings or testing required no one can
predict or understand the specifics of
the testing required leaving unskilled
decision makers in the way of timely
diagnosis so from my perspective the
only thing that pre-authorization
requirement does is introduce
inefficiency suffering and potential for
actual harm and medical negligence so I
strongly encourage the passage of this
bill to save everyone time money and
distress and possibly alive thank
you thank you any questions from the
committee seeing n thank you very much
for your testimony thank you so uh Heidi
are you back
yet good morning Mr chairman yes I am
back okay sorry for that thank you very
much for accommodating I'm doing two
zooms um so again uh good morning uh Mr
chairman and members of the committee um
for the record my name is Heidi croll I
work at Gallagher Callahan and gartell
I'm here today representing ahip which
stands for America's health insurance
plans we are the trade Association for
um health insurance carriers um we ahip
is opposed to House Bill 199 I'm sorry
191 because it will restrict and
undermine the use of prior authorization
which is a critical tool used to protect
patient safety and promote
evidence-based treatments and improved
outcomes um we also oppose house build
191 because we believe it could lead to
Upward pressure on health insurance
premium at a time when New Hampshire
residents and businesses um cannot
afford higher
prices um I want to cover kind of three
areas today one is just um a little bit
about what prior authorization is and
why it's important um second some
background information on prior
authorization in New Hampshire um and I
did send you an email last night um with
a two-page document or um and then uh
third I wanted to just cover kind of uh
alternative uh non-legislative solutions
to hille
191 um so first a little bit about prior
authorization and why it's important um
Health Plans use medical management
tools um such as prior authorization uh
step therapy formularies provider
networks to ensure that patients receive
access to Safe effective and evident
space Care at an affordable cost um
prior authorization also helps to P put
certain patients on carrier's radar um
sooner rather than later so that the
carrier can actually help with patient
care coordination namely getting the
right care uh at the right setting at
the right
time prior authorization also targets
certain prescription drugs and Medical
Services um that are prone to a wide
variation in provider practices um and
the potential for either overuse
underuse or misuse of services um which
of course can impact uh have an impact
on patient care and safety as well as
costs um when a prior authorization is
required and and not every drug or
service is has a prior authorization in
fact it's a small minority um but when
it is required the prior authorization
Protocols are developed and tailored um
very specifically to the particular drug
or the medical service in question um so
there is no one-size fits-all when it
comes to prior authorization
protocols um prior authorization
Protocols are routinely reviewed and
adjusted um in response to changes in
the safety uh Effectiveness or value of
an existing drug or medical procedure um
as well as in response to new medical
guidance or or new drugs or procedures
coming to Market um that may provide
more um effective and cost-effective
treatment uh Federal programs such as
Medicaid and Medicare recognize the
value of prior authorization as do
providers um especially if providers
that are in value-based reimbursement
models um so when those providers are in
those kind of contracts value based care
contracts um where they have a stake in
patient outcomes as well as cost and
savings um the providers themselves
actually um also develop and use prior
authorization protocols to help them
deliver highquality medically necessary
care and a cost effective manner so um
the point is that even providers
recognize the value of prior
authorization
um turning to the background um and
information on prior authorization in
New Hampshire um first I wanted to let
you know that um to the best of ahip's
knowledge uh other states do not have
laws or Provisions similar to House Bill
191 um ahip reviewed its database of
laws related to prior authorization in
other states and was unable to find laws
similar to the ones proposed in house
bille
191 um secondly uh in the handout that I
emailed to you you'll see a description
of how carriers develop their
utilization Management Programs um
including prior authorization and the
bottom line is that um utilization
management policies are developed
through a very rigorous process um to
ensure that they reflect um the most
current scientific data and also
clinical
knowledge um third it's important to
know that in recent years the
legislature has made quite a number of
significant ific amendments to New
Hampshire's prior authorization laws um
including five changes that were made
last year pursuant to the passage of
House Bill 1280 and House Bill 1639 um
the carriers came to the table and did a
lot of negotiating with the hospital
Association the medical society and
others um legislators as well um those
changes took effect uh between July 29th
of 2020 and January 1st of this year and
we think it's important to give those
changes some time um and see what their
impacts are before we start making more
significant uh
changes finally it's important to
understand that we do have uh consumer
protection Provisions um in RSA
420e relative to lure of medical
utilization review entities and these
consumer uh uh protection Provisions
include time periods within which prior
authorization must be determined uh
Provisions for expedited review and the
right for both an internal and external
review um and I will also mention that
the carriers meet um national standards
as well um around uh their prior
authorization
protocols so finally um turning to um
non-legislative Solutions uh in our
opinion legislating legislatively
mandated restrictions like those
proposed in house bow 191 are far too
broad and um simply not appropriate uh
and we believe that there are
non-legislative
Solutions uh we have spoken with the
providers um and offered that if the
providers are running into problems with
a particular prior authorization
requirement that one or more carriers
have you know particular to a particular
drug or particular service um that we
are you know the medical directors and
others at the carriers are are all ears
and more than willing to um have
discussions about amending particular
prior authorization protocols and in
fact um this has happened historically
um where uh you know one or more New
Hampshire doctors will approach the
medical director of a of a um carrier
and uh make them aware of some
information either um late breaking news
uh about um a particular procedure or
just maybe a problem that they're having
and the carriers are more than willing
to work um to try to uh see if it's
appropriate to amend the protocols um
but to the best of my knowledge um the
providers have not of late um taken the
carriers up on this
offer um the other thing that we did
offer is to um take specific examples of
the pro of the you know uh problems that
the providers are running into and try
to crosswalk that with the use of the
electronic prior authorization systems
that the carriers have um could help U
minimize or even avoid um some of the
problems in so um that's the other thing
that I wanted to mention is that um
electronic prior authorization is a tool
that can be used to kind of you know
ease the administrative burden of prior
authorization um that the providers um
you know have mentioned without losing
the benefits of prior authorization um
so that's uh something I wanted to
mention that we have um we have those
tools that can streamline the process
and reduce the administrative burden for
everyone involved um so short we
strongly object to House Bill 199 uh 191
um because we feel it will undermine a
critical tool used to protect patient
safety and promote evidence-based
treatments um and uh we are concerned it
will drive up premiums for New Hampshire
citizens and businesses and with that
I'd be happy to answer any questions um
thank you very much for your time and
consideration uh um we do have a
question uh representative
abson uh thank you Mr chair and thank
you than you for taking my question um
just like the last bill do you have an
estimate for how much you think this
might increase the costs for a premiums
as a percentage
basis it's a great question I don't um
but I can say that the way the bill is
written it is very broad so this would
uh impact prior authorizations um and
drugs across the board Services across
the board so it um has the potential to
touch um every single service or
prescription medication that a patient
might
receive great I'm seeing no more
questions thank you very much thank
you uh I will next call
on uh Nancy erson boia Bonia let me see
so you if she would just raise her hand
there we go and I can promote you the
panelist
and there you are
hopefully are you there Nancy you're
muted am I unmuted now you're unmuted
now you're good okay good morning um my
name is Nancy erson Bona I'm a retina
specialist which is a subsp specialist
uh within
Opthalmology I practice in Bedford New
Hampshire I've been here for in New
Hampshire for almost 16 years and
um I was notified about this bill
yesterday and I wanted to um weigh in on
the bill itself but the broader ISS
issue of prior
authorization um I think it's very
appropriate that I'm following um Heidi
croll because I could not disagree more
with pretty much everything she said and
I'm going to start by saying retina
specialists in the United States are the
number one Medicare
billers drug-wise and that is
because we use FDA approved Medicaid s
such as IIA lucentis B ofu drugs which
were
designed to treat macular degeneration
diabetic
retinopathy vascular diseases all of
which are sight threatening and
blinding without these
medications during my training for
instance over 25 years
ago we had no effective treatments and
people tradition Ally went legally blind
from their disease with the Advent of
these medications over the last 15 years
we've reduced we've been able to
maintain Vision in 90% of our wet Mac
degeneration cases and we have reduced
diabetic blindness which is the leading
reason why young diabetics lose their
jobs go on disability and are out of the
workforce these drugs are very
expensive because they're FDA
approved and over the
last 48 months and as of January 1 the
burden on providers in private practice
to use these drugs for our patients is
prohibited um just to use some of her
comments that providers have not taken
up the
offer
to
discuss issues with medical directors on
the use of these
drugs is first of all not even the issue
they have as of January 1 for instance
United healthc
care they're all of the Medicare
Advantage plans across the board have
instituted stepwise therapy and PR
authorization and to the point
where it takes my solo practice more
than one full-time equivalent on the
phone all day trying to get prior
offs and we are now being told and this
is all new as of January 1 so when she
said give time for these former bills to
take event January 1 marked the start of
all of these Medicare Advantage Plans in
particular and the commercial United
Etna Sigma Blue Cross Blue Shield
Harvard Pilgrim stride to
reverse or let ex ex
the request that was made by the by HHS
in 2020 because of covid to back off on
prior
off they let January 1 be the end of of
that Arena and now we are being told
that not only do we have to have prior
offs for things we didn't used to have
including a vastin which is the off
label medication they're trying to force
us to use instead of IA and Luc sentus
because it's
$65 they're actually making us go
through a prior off to get a $65 drug
for injection every time the patient
comes and the prior
off this in this bill the six month
prior off to me should be the minimum if
you had any idea how long we sit on the
phone for a single patient single prior
off we're talking sometimes an hour and
45 minutes and she talked about these
electronic options for prior oth that is
a joke because we have a problem in New
Hampshire with our availity website most
of these
plans we have tried going
online we end up having to go on the
phone as a matter of fact the carriers
themselves tell us the best way to get
to them is on the phone not trying
electronically then they tell us as of
January 1 that they have well human and
others have told us that before that
they have 14 business days to decide
whether this patient needs treatment in
the meantime my patient can go blind
irreversibly
blind and
you know compounding all of that is now
um Miss craw said that prior offs are
essential because they're evidence-based
therapy and for patient safety who is
she
kidding we know our Academy has been
fighting and been in this in the federal
legislation showing that over 90% of
every prior off for intravital
injections which is what I'm talking
about is approved so why are we being
delayed care and having to go through
this
continuous prior off burden and Blue
Cross Blue
Shield the other um Miss Dunlap was
saying you know how Blue Cross Blue
Shield is is
um their prior off is for safety and all
this other stuff they're a perfect
example after fighting and fighting and
fighting for prior off on their
patients we have patients that have been
getting injections for three years and
every time I do an injection on certain
patients Blue Cross Blue Shield holds up
the payment asks for the records reviews
the treatment this is after the prior
off procedure so I know I'm going on and
on but all I can say is Bill 191 to me
forget being broad it is so specific it
is so limited the least these patients
deserve is a six-month prior off the
transfer of care obviously is more of a
a facility
issue um but when it comes to private
practice and patient care my patients
are currently in a very very precarious
situation because almost 40% of seniors
now are signing on to these Medicare
Advantage
plans all of them require prior offs now
all of them have instituted stepwise
therapy and they are quoting studies
that's the other thing that Miss croll
said about
evidence-based they don't know the
beginnings of how to interpret these
studies they are taking the studies out
of context they are putting statements
in their in their plans that say that um
you might show that the patient has
failed on a vastin which is forcing us
to use an off-label drug non FDA
approved with safety issues over FDA
approved drugs in and of itself is
unethical but for them to quote studies
saying they're equivalent when they
haven't even
studied the the 15 years of data that's
out there that shows that some drugs are
superior and I after 16 years of
training I like to be the one to decide
which drug my patient gets so with that
I urge you to consider not only
approving 191 but really looking
into um why they're saying premiums are
going to go up they're going to go up
for one reason and one reason only
because they're going to have to prior
off the appropriate treatment and drugs
of patients not because they had to have
a prior off procedure to do it there's
absolutely no reason in one 91 why any
premium should go up if anything it
should go down if you're getting
transfer of care to a a less expensive
facility and your prior offs are for six
months your own staff won't have to be
on the phone with providers every day of
the week for we we now have some Blue
Cross Blue Shield people giving us 30
days one drug one injection and making
us go back and get another prior
off so with that I thank you for your
time and um I can take any
questions um yeah before I take
questions um I'm not sure this
legislation is going to affect medic
Medicare or
Medicaid I I did not say Medicare or
Medicaid as a matter of fact I
wish the problem this bill will affect
is your commercial Medicare Medicaid
replacement plans because they run under
they are commercial and they're prior
offs Medicare does not chire prior
o okay all right uh any other questions
from the
committee seeing none we thank you very
much for your testimony thanks okay next
up is uh Ellen Wood also she from SE
Coast General so Ellen if you just okay
there you
are and need a panelist
and you are
on
[Music]
and you're still
muted there you go hi okay thanks so
much for this opportunity um I don't
know oh I can start a video too okay um
I'm a practice manager for general
surgery practice
um and I've been uh working with them
for 17 years and I would concur so much
of what Nancy just said um again we're
general surgery so it's very different
than
Opthalmology um
but pre-authorization at this point um
Anthem uses a company by the name of aim
and I am not exagerating when I say I
have a staff member that will be on the
phone for two or three hours waiting for
a
representative um and you're not getting
a representative that
um is um knowledgeable for the most part
they're just taking the data not really
even aware of the data they're taking um
many times we do MRI for breast cancer
and you can they're wearing blinders
they have um little to no medical
experience and they're making a lot of
times the determination about whether
this um oth is is expedited or not um
you know a woman's waiting for her MRI
because her pathology has said that she
has a um a possibly invasive um breast
cancer um and it's it's really um
it's time consuming a waste of time um
for many of the
authorizations um and there's little to
no value I would like to talk about when
they're talking about the increase of um
costs I've been in the business for a
long time and my understanding was that
they put authorizations in place to save
money so I think it's sort of
interesting that now they're saying it's
going to cost money um I'll also address
the fact that she's mentioning something
about calling the um
or discussing it with the medical
director that is
um it's I I've I've I've done it um for
a procedure that continually got um
denied but it took me over a year to try
to finally get somebody that would
understand what it was that they were
denying that made no sense and at no
point did I ever fully get to the
medical director and this was Anthem um
United Health Care for the second
procedure piece of it United healthc
Care uses a company by the name of
optim so you have to send the claim in
then they say you know uh NOP you didn't
off the second procedure we need notes
and we'll send notes in and I can't tell
you how many times sometimes two or
three times and I'm not exaggerating
that we will fax the whole record for
this patient to get um the surgery paid
for at 50% mind you because it's the
second procedure so more often than not
since they figure you're in there then
they're only going to pay you at
50% um you don't get somebody that is
English as their primary language and
those are the people that most likely
are reviewing our medical records and
that's disappointing to say the least um
the other thing is a long time ago there
was um and I would challenge the
insurance companies for their um you
know what are they using as data because
a long time ago they had data that said
if a provider's office continually did a
pre-authorization and got approved and I
would tell you less than 1% of our
pre-authorizations are denied in general
surgery so in my practice in any event
um which tells me that my doctors are
doing nothing but medical necessity um
surgeries and medical necessity
procedures uh but anyway there was a
carrier I think it might have even been
siga that would give um a practice or a
provider um almost like a gold card so
they didn't have to go through the pre
offs again and again and again when in
fact they had a proven track record of
getting all their pre Ops approved at
100% because everything that they did
was necessary and then they followed
through maybe with the operative note to
you know with the icd10 codes and the
procedure codes
um I I don't know why that was thrown
out and I don't even remember but it was
a long time ago but it was something
worthwhile and I would tell you just
recently we had somebody with a Medicaid
and her prior o was uh approved but for
some reason maybe the the gal couldn't
get to uh it was an MRI for her breast
and she had breast cancer but she
couldn't get to her appointment and
possibly the hospital was delayed
because of covid and recently they were
packed and so that was a condition too
um and of course we're getting patients
that cancel because they're afraid to go
to the hospital but anyway her prior oth
was um expired by one
day my staff member had to start from
scratch to get her prior auth approved
again is that a good utilization of e
expertise or time it's not that's insane
but you know the companies say well I'm
sorry we can't transfer all that
information you have to start from
scratch I I I have no
idea with anybody with a an ounce of
intelligence would put that procedure in
place it makes no
sense um and that's and that's basically
it um I think to um Extended to six
months at the very least is um
especially in this climate is should go
without saying um
and don't believe everything you hear
from the um from the big insurance
companies than very much okay do we have
any questions from the committee members
uh see them we are we are running a
little bit behind here uh so next I'll
call on Nick carer
canaro and if Nick you raise your
hand
and there he is
okay go
ahead
thank you representa hunt can you hear
me yes I can all right I I was on there
I'm I've signed in in support but I was
kind of a placeholder in case Paula
minahan couldn't get on so I fully
support what she said but um other than
that I have no further comment thank you
okay all right great thank you uh and
now we have Ahad F fad F
fad is he
[Music]
on if you're onad just uh well he's an A
so he should be right up here unless
he's this phone
number oad are you
on said he wanted to
speak
uh ones going
twice they don't
see see him okay um how about uh Cynthia
Martin there you go
and promote to
panelist and you're on
Cynthia Cindy excuse
me cth
here and you just have to unmute
yourself there we go can you hear me yes
okay wonderful um
I am so happy to be able to
say something about this issue um I
appreciate having three minutes to talk
about an issue that I've watched
just just unfold over my 30 years um as
a practice manager in multiple
offices um I right now I'm managing the
practice um of a retina specialist um in
Bedford and Dr Nancy Bona
and the other practice manager Miss Wood
I cannot tell you I cannot addess enough
of what they speak of and how um
unbelievable this prior authorization
process is every single thing that they
said I kept writing notes and I'm like
yes everybody that we talked to I'm on
the phone I talk to these people they
don't know what they're authorizing they
don't even know what they're talking
about um the inefficiencies in the
utilization management programs that
they speak of um is
unfathomable the um urgent uh emergent
Rush of a PA that's necessary the
soonest you can get it is 72 hours it's
unbelievable what has happened and how
things have
deteriorated um and especially when I
work in uh retina specialty now where
we're talking about sight people's
eyesight not that I'm putting anything
the cancer the breast cancers um but the
people's Vision if you're sight if your
sight
was
threatened or that of a loved one and
you couldn't get the treatment that you
needed because of a prior authorization
for a
treatment it's just it's criminal it's
absolutely
criminal um so I I know we don't have a
lot of time I just wanted to reiterate
that I experience daily what these
people uh are speaking to and um I say
Bravo to anyone that is going to listen
to The Physicians who have the expertise
and the knowledge they are the ones that
need to determine the care the level of
care that their patients need not
some you know insurance company or
person behind the phone that has
absolutely no experience thank
you thank you anybody else would like to
testify ask a question see none uh okay
uh Tyler you're raising your
hand uh yeah I believed I was registered
to testify yes yeah know I I still was
going to come to I was going to have you
wrap up at the end here so I got got two
more people to speak okay so uh next is
David
Hutton so David if uh you just raise
your hand then I can find
you
and I don't see any any raised
hand so uh one more chance no okay uh so
la last lobbyist before I have Tyler is
um
is where is um Mora Weston did I yeah
Mora did I have you speak yet yeah okay
here we go there you go
Mar good
morning you have to unmute yourself Mora
thank you can you hear me yes I can okay
I'm sorry for that thank you very much
um good morning Mr chair members of the
committee my name is Mora Weston and I'm
here today to testify on behalf of dairy
medical uh Tom Buchanan the CEO of dairy
medical had hoped to testify today
however he's currently um testifying in
another committee so get the B team and
I'll do my best uh I'm here this morning
to express support for House Bill 191
but we would like to encourage the
committee to consider an amendment to
actually expand its
application Dair Medical Center is an
independent 60 provider primary care
Physician Group in Southern New
Hampshire we see about 45,000 patients
and on average we see about a thousand
people a day we believe that prior
authorizations have turned into
burdensome a burdensome function that
drives up costs reduces consumer choice
and operates outside the general view of
insurance
regulations while this bill is a good
start we don't think it goes far
enough possible changes that would
strengthen consumer protections and
reduce administrative burdens would
include uh a couple of different um
ideas that we
have first all clinical prior off
guidelines used to make clinical
determinations to cover Services need to
be available to the contracted provider
all too often lower level employees in
health plans render decisions that are
not consistent with appropriate medical
guidelines
this forces peer-to-peer to-peer
discussions which are timec consuming
for
Physicians and not the highest and best
use of the provider's
time outside of that physician time
Dairy medical employs five people solely
for the purpose of handling prior
authorizations we need those prior
guidelines and they need to be
accessible and they are
not for an entity like very
medical prior authorization the prior
authorization process is real money it's
a real expense we pride ourselves on
being a lowcost highquality provider
generally our cost of patient care is on
average
15% below other providers in the state
in an outpatient Primary Care setting
like Dairy medical our patients seek the
best medical treatment options and we
seek prior authorizations for their care
uh with any number of different
providers and
Facilities prior authorizations should
not be a tool to reduce competition and
keep a patient beholden to a certain
Health Care
System prior offs for Diagnostic testing
should be provider agnostic this means
an approved diagnostic study should
allow the patient to go to any
contracted provider for that service
currently the prior off process requires
the name of the facility to be included
in the prior auth approval patients have
little choice of where to go and if they
want that changed it's cumbersome and
many originating providers are unwilling
to change it in the age of six to
$122,000 deductibles patients should
have the right to go where they want
within a plan
Network especially given the range of
pricing that exists in New Hampshire
that the patient is liable for
therefore we encourage the committee to
expand the conversation around Prior
authorizations we would be happy to work
with the sponsors in the committee on
prior authorization reform and
specifically on language relative to
prior authorization portability we
believe that this step would increase
transparency and allow for greater
consumer choice in their health care
decision making and reduce the total
overall costs of healthc care services
in New Hampshire thank you for your time
thank you you willing to take a question
sure uh representative pusk has a
question uh thank you uh Miss Weston uh
of John pusk uh Darry New Hampshire ATI
good morning a patient at Dairy Medical
Center of Dr John Wheeler fabulous um I
saw on my email before I ran upstairs
here that you have submitted uh an email
testimony uh to us yes is is your
recommendations or are your
recommendations for expanded uh
portability and those issues in that
email I didn't have a chance to read it
yes thank you for the question um the
test the written testimony is more of a
summary um my oral comments went a bit
beyond that and we would we did not
provide a proposed amendment in the in
the written remarks but I am happy to
work on some language and submit it for
consideration well thank you very much
certainly uh well we do have one more
hand that just came up we have Dr
Brewster and I'm gonna Bill I'm gonna
promote you to
panelist so you and he's a former are
you former medical director are you
still the medical director what of
Harvard
bill can you hear me now yes there you
go perfect so first off I want to
apologize I don't normally bring my dogs
to hearings but I have two of them and
they're usually quietest when they sit
next to me so I apologize they bark um
good morning chairman hunt Vice chair of
pusk and members of the committee my
name for the record is Bill Brewster I'm
vice president of New Hampshire market
for Harvard Pilgrim Healthcare and not
for-profit Health Service services
company I previously served as Harvard
pilgrims medical director for New
Hampshire overseeing the evaluation of
medical necessity appropriateness and
efficiency of health care services for
all of our members I'm also a
board-certified Internal Medicine doc
who practiced in New Hampshire from 1987
to 2018 and I've also served on the
board of two nonprofit hospitals in New
Hampshire thank you for the giving me
the time to speak to you this morning on
House Bill
191 I have a lot of concerns with the
bill and how it will impact how we
manage the care of our Members First the
bill requires all prior RS to be valid
for six months six months is not
appropriate for all services or
treatments in fact sometimes it's not
even long enough um and we will you know
routinely give oneyear uh approvals for
many of the drugs where the condition
isn't expected to change it's going to
continue um all of our prior are service
or treatment specific they're they
address what is a typical length of time
that some somebody might need to be in
an acute rehab or
hospital um and again just to reassure
everybody it's not uh gcha medicine it's
not arbitrary um we really do base them
on input from published evidence-based
medicine and clinical experts uh when we
have prior Ross you'll see a site at the
bottom all the list of the different uh
articles that we reviewed so that if
somebody has a concern about that we can
address it um we also try to make prior
Ro easy uh we offer electronic prior oth
process and if something gets moved out
I heard that commented on if something
does get pushed out because of covid or
prior to co there were reasons why um
things had to be moved out and all the
provider needs to do is change the date
in the electronic prior off that doesn't
need to be PRI uh reauthorized um again
to try to make it easier for the
providers um as far as the last section
of the bill on patient transfers uh we
consider any request to transfer a
patient to a low level of care as an
urgent pre-service request all of the
requests are reviewed within 24 to 48
hours per ncqa um ncq as a National
Committee for quality assurance um it's
a nonprofit that uses evidence-based
medicine that we all have to adhere to
to be
credential
um one the the only priori that we have
is on authorization to transport
somebody um to a lower level of care
again I think Paula and others had
mentioned that transfers from hospital
to acute Hospital you know from frisbee
where I work to Portsmouth or or Mass
General we don't require any prior Roth
for that but any that is an elective
non-emergency
transfer um if somebody's using an
ambulance we we'd ask for Med medical
justification for why they need an
ambulance rather than a wheelchair van
and we'll approve it if in fact that
they they can't be in a wheelchair or
they can't be transported safely that
way and and again frankly I mean you can
all imagine um we don't want members to
be in acute care any longer than
necessary you know having a Bed full
I've been on diversion at hospitals I've
had to move people around um we want
people to be able to get into the
hospital when they need to get into we
need them to get to a lower uh level of
care when they uh when that's
appropriate as well um I'm personally
and I know we as a company are happy to
work continue to work with the hospitals
if they have specific concerns about how
we do things um but I I haven't had
specific examples to really be able to
address or you know fix a problem if
there is one and would like to continue
to work with them outside of the
legislative Arena
possible again I I tell my staff it's
not our money it's your money if you're
a member of ours it's the employer's
money um we need to manage that
responsibly we need to try to keep the
cost of care as affordable as possible
and Broad limits on what plans can do in
the space will only serve to increase
costs for members and I for all all of
those reasons I urge you to find Senate
Bill 191 inexpedient to legislate thank
you for your time and happy to take any
questions uh well I thought we had a
question but representative pusk put his
hand down so I guess we're all set uh
thank you so much thank you very much uh
for weighing in okay now Tyler you're
I'll have you wrap up for
us thank you so Tyler Brandon with the
New Hampshire insurance department and
uh we don't have a position on the bill
first thing I want to do is clarify I
think one of the questions that came up
um this would be a insurance change and
uh so it would not apply to the Medicare
Advantage plans which are regulated by
the federal government it would also not
apply to the Managed Care organizations
that are under contract with DHHS for
Medicaid um as usual it would also not
apply to self-funded populations that
are using a carrier like Anthem to
administer their benefits this is
typically the case when we have
Commercial Insurance legislation um one
of the first things I I noticed about
this legislation it's a little different
is it's it's General applies to all
services products um it's in the statute
and the Managed Care statute that would
apply to any network-based products when
you look at the other prior
authorization restrictions or areas in
statute they're all targeting certain
types of services or providers or circum
ances such as obstetrical Care Mental
Health Services something like that so
it's unusual to see something that would
be as as broad as um as this legislation
would be um I actually can't think of
another prior authorization change that
would be as broad the um generally
speaking legislation like this would
weaken a Care's ability to perform
utilization management case management
through prior authorization and uh
certainly we we hear kind of some the
the frustrations in the provider
Community um it does prior authorization
is a utilization management tool that
does control cost to an extent so
despite what might be inefficiencies
doing away with it or restricting it we
should see some inflationary pressure on
on Healthcare claims costs and uh and
and turn our premiums um it is worth all
also recognizing and I think it's been
mentioned but maybe not perfectly clear
sometimes prior authorization is always
granted it's just a part of the
administrative process of a carrier
flagging a particular patient so they
can use case managers they can
coordinate care they can be involved we
have to remember that sometimes when you
go to a hospital or you go to another
health care provider the insurer may not
know about it until really until the
claim comes in without some sort of
prior authorization process the other
reality is that uh Health Care uh
findings do change sometimes quickly it
could be a service is now deemed high-
risk for a particular population or
maybe it's even high- risk within a
particular provider setting the um the
other consideration is an insure tends
to be able to see kind of a bird's eye
view of a patient's health care
experience so something like a a number
of CT scans or something that just has a
lot of radiation exposure over time
maybe being done by different providers
that's not something an individual
provider may be aware of but a carrier
could Implement um tracking and
identifying those types of
services um the uh so that's most of it
as it relates to the prior o there is
the the segment that does deal with the
transfers and um I thought this was also
perhaps trying to Target particular
circumstances such as people being in
the ER or otherwise held up and because
intuitively a carrier has a business
interest in transferring a patient to a
lower cost setting the language though
makes me a little bit uncomfortable
because it it could be open to
interpretation um it does make reference
to the carrier not providing
accommodations and that's that's a
little unclear exactly what that means
and then of course paying that the per
day rate where that assumes that the
patient there is is is receiving
services that are paid on a per day so
it sounded initially it looked like it
was intended to Target very specific
circumstances but I couldn't actually
understand what providing accommodations
could mean in every context so as a
regulator that would be um enforcing the
the the requirement that's a little less
clear than what we' ideally like um so
that's probably everything I I I can
cover that would be helpful happy to
answer any questions though you might
have uh don't any
okay a question yes thank you again for
your testimony um we've heard two kinds
of testimony today uh insurance
companies uh Representatives saying that
prior
authorization reduces costs and improves
uh Ser proves care and people
representing uh various provider uh
Health Care Providers saying just the
opposite and it's almost like two uh uh
statements of Faith but I wonder if you
or any of the other people who have
testified could after the after this uh
hearing could send us some documentary
evidence to support that it either
increases costs or decreases costs I
just don't know if I want to believe it
just because people said it so I this is
my question is if anyone can do this
would you please get back to us with
evidence that in fact it is saving cost
it's not saving cost it is improving
care it's not improving care from
whatever studies thank you very
much you want I think along those lines
things I I would kind of add is is that
this is a competitive area that that one
carrier may actually manage their prior
authorization better than another
carrier which means that uh they're
going to reap the benefits of of doing
it in a a better more efficient way I
think to the extent there's a debate
about whether or not it saves in general
um I mean clar the carriers would have a
business interest in and reducing their
their claims costs as much as possible
um it not be public information but I
think if uh you were to sort of explore
some of the discussions between a large
provider delivery system and a carrier
about assuming risk for health care
services than compitation accountable
care organizations other sort of global
budgets providers are often a little bit
uncomfortable assuming responsibility
for utilization management and prior
authorization if a carrier is p all the
risk to the provider then they're less
interested so that may be kind of an
interesting area to explore to the
extent who is actually at risk for these
claims expenditures and whether or not
prior authorization or other medical
management tools are
used uh representative aberson has a
question the mute button uh thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question me lo my hand um is there a way
to amend this bill to remove some of the
problems and issues that were brought up
but still retaining the protection for
prior authorization so the
authorizations still remain
valid I would say
yes um I mean I think that there are
ways to modify the bill to perhaps make
um perhaps give the
flexibility uh that is necessary or
helpful to a carrier but um but I think
at at the end of the day it's going to
be a compromise one way or another as I
started with uh it may be worth
exploring whether or not the the issues
are most acute in particular settings or
particular providers or whether you know
considerations for the what is most
efficient that a carrier is doing but um
uh clearly every bill could be made a
little bit
better well said uh representative Terry
has a question thank you Mr chairman uh
commissioner Brandon we've heard from uh
a number of uh individuals uh today who
have expressed uh
frustration uh in uh dealing with
receiving uh prior authorization for
medications and services in in your role
as commissioner of the the department
have you received uh the same sorts of
uh complaints uh from uh
providers um and to what extent have you
received those and how have you
addressed
them so the insurance Department's
primary focus is consumer so to the
extent complaints come in from a a
consumer those are the ones we we
prioritize and indeed there um we have
received complaints in the past about
sort of getting access to health care
services and potentially a carrier
feeling differently about uh a potential
treatment um being prescribed for a
particular member then that the provider
does there are actually several levels
of sort of appeals that a consumer can
go through to deal with um barriers
being put up by a carrier and some of
those are actually in statut so um we do
try to handle these as as we can but um
at the end of the day you end up with
some disagreement occasionally between a
provider and a carrier that being said
the the sort of external appeal process
actually does allow um a a medical care
provider outside of the department and
not involved in the dispute to weigh in
on on medical necessity and uh and the
treatment that's being um intended a
followup please forther question me
inquire thank you um with respect to the
uh appeals
process um can you would you
characterize the approximate uh length
of time uh for most of those appeals to
be heard and resolved and do you find
that the appeals process is adequate to
remedy most of the cons uh complaints
from
consumers yeah I'm not sure I could
weigh in on the average time it takes to
resolve a dispute but there is a
expedite appeal process which has to be
resolved within either 48 or 72 I
believe hours but uh but in general I
think there is a fair amount of sort of
comfort with those protections and um I
don't think we've seen legislation to
change the appeals process for quite a
while so I think that would suggest that
it's working as
intended great thank you very much uh
all right now um I think we're done now
for uh I don't know I got another hand
when up uh yeah uh uh uh Miss Miss Uh
Wood we're we're really kind of full up
now but you can certainly submit some
more testimony if you want like if
anybody has any more comments they want
to make uh please feel free to to send
St in and with that I will close the
public hearing and because we're we're
now really really behind but on a
somewhat similar subject so uh we'll go
right into it and Patrick Pat I see you
guys your hand up so I'm going to
promote him up to
panelists and um it will open up the
public hearing on
1605 in here from um representative
brammy good morning representative
brammy and I'm sorry about the
delay thank you Mr chair um for the
record uh State red P brammy Rockingham
stratum yeah Pat we had the same problem
before you're louder you know I've for
for for a while it was good now I was
just told this morning on ways the means
that it was out had to speak up I've
tried every setting closer just get
closer I'm I'm as Clos as I'm gonna so
you're gonna see my you don't see my
face you don't see anything so camera
okay good that's good so uh go ahead uh
again this bill is identical to a bill
that I had filed last term uh that time
it went to the labor committee where it
passed unanimous uh and and on the floor
in the consent calendar
and again like hundreds of other bills
it uh never had a hearing and it and it
wound up uh tabled so I refiled this
bill uh Mr chair can I ask a question is
this an early bill is this going to go
to labor or you you f not not an early
Bill no okay just want to understand
thank you so I was approached by uh
several mental health uh practitioners
who who want to come out out from
underneath non-compete clauses in their
employment contracts
uh just for uh Clarity there were five
license types that would come under this
bill uh uh four fall fall under RSA
33- that's pastoral uh psychotherapist
clinical social workers clinical Mental
Health Counselors marriage and family
therapists and then there's one that
falls under RSA 329 DB
psychologists uh members of this
committee who have been around for a
while uh may remember that we have done
similar things for other health
professionals in
2016 we did a similar thing and created
uh we we got Physicians and surgeons out
from underneath the noncompete Clauses
and that was that is in statute RSA 329
colon
31-a then in
2018 we did the same for nurses and uh
podiatrists uh the nurses are under RSA
32 2 6-b col
45a and the podiatrists are under RSA
315 col
18 what I want to point out is that if
you go to those statutes you will you
will see that the language that I have
in this bill is identical to those four
professions okay just understand that so
I just stole that language and was the
language that that is in these statute
so that the language has been tested
over number of years now
this bill's language as it did for
Physicians nurses podiatrists Etc only
applies to new contracts or renewals of
contracts entered into on or after the
effective date of the
section so you may say well why mental
health workers
now uh there's a few points we are in
the midst of a mental health and
addiction epidemic these mental health
workers are a Lifeline to their clients
they there's a true practitioner client
relationship between them if these
practitioners want to advance in their
careers and move onto another practice
in their geographic area uh many current
contracts prevent them from doing so the
norm that you see is a 30 mile radius
you can work outside that 30 mile radius
and in many of those cases they would
have to sever the relationship with the
with their
clients so that is
uh the the basic Bill uh that basically
was the house position last year uh I
know we have a new house so there are
many I know there's several
practitioners who are going to be
testifying behind me uh Mr chair will
take questions uh but when it comes to
more specifics about the situation I'm
sure those others would do a good better
job than I testifying but I'll take any
questions if there are
any uh yes representative Herbert has a
question
you're muted
Chris thank you chairman and thank you
representative abami my question is uh
actually I'm I can't believe it but I'm
kind of stealing Max Abra Max's uh
question have you noticed uh in the
other uh um non-competes that you
proposed and got pasted that it it
increased uh cost or decreased cost or
what were the impacts the real world
impacts that you may be aware of
from uh the non-competes that you
already uh I don't know if you limited
them you limited the their application
okay well first I want to say hello to
representative Herbert who who was who
was on the ways of means with me for a
term or two um
so understand that uh the the Physicians
surgeons nurses podiatrists I had
nothing to do with uh that that there
were other people who filed those bills
uh I know I think in 2018 it was Senator
Sherman uh Senator uh
sanborn's uh Bill uh that was passed so
uh as as far as any negative or positive
impacts I I I don't know I don't have
the answer to
that okay um see no questions I'm sorry
about the delay and I'd saying hindsight
I wish you had I I totally missed what
this bill was about I i' see it's a
non-compete somehow I had it was a prior
o bill but representative hun I I should
have called you say if we could should
called me I would have had it vacated in
a h beat but uh yeah but we're not in
session for a while I don't know can we
can we vacate without being in session
have to go to the floor no the hearing's
already been happen so youate now well
okay well have fun with that funny time
but next time next time
you'll be in good hands with those
testifying after me I'm heading back to
ways it means now thank you all right
thank you okay so I'll Now call
on
um Carrie
uh Jas Jason Chason must be a French
name
yeah uh and I am gonna allow oh I'm yeah
here we go promoting the panelist
Gary and welcome to the Commerce
Committee you do have to unmute yourself
okay all right I think here I am hi
there yes I'm Dr Carrie chassen thank
you guys for um for giving us some time
today to chat about this issue um I'm my
my version of um when I when we
testified on this bill last time it was
heard um it um I basically just was here
to tell my personal story um and because
I was directly affected by a non-compete
that really um impacted my life in a
really negative way that I have turned
around into a things are fine now but um
but it it messed things up so I'm here
to just tell my story so um I'm a
licensed clinical psychologist um who
moved to New Hampshire from Rhode Island
where I had been in a private practice
um to New Hampshire to be closer to my
husbands and my family um that was now a
few years ago um and in order to accept
an offer from the single owner Private
Practice in Portsmith I was required to
sign a contract and non-compete
non-solicitation that dictated that
currently and for two years after my
employment ends I cannot practice
Psychotherapy at A Private Practice
Group practice hospital or medical
center within a 30m radius of the office
um which I negotiated down from 40 miles
um the owners and my goal had been to
work full-time so scheduling
approximately 25 to 35 people per week
um um to initially help build my
practice I made calls to local
professionals to network I wrote pieces
for the practice's monthly plog provided
free talks at a local community center
and spoke to parents at a school you
know at schools for presentations um
after having been there for almost 10
months my schedule was not even close to
being full um in my best week I saw 15
people which happened twice um and they
were in my third month of employment um
the the mean was I saw about 10 people
per week and I still only worked three
days because that's how I started things
out um I had been actively involved in
doing what she had asked as a way to
increase my case load talks written
materials for the vog parenting New
Hampshire article made phone calls to
other Professionals in the area and
similar things um we had two meetings uh
where I a couple months apart where I
had asked to meet to discuss ways to
increase my income um including taking
in network clients which she said I was
not permitted to do it was a practice
where we were only um we didn't accept
insurance and she wasn't willing to let
that happen um for me in this situation
um after about 10 months of working
there I was approached um about a
part-time opportunity to work at unh's
Counseling Center as a way to supplement
my income on a temporary basis while I
wasn't making a sufficient amount of
money um the position was offered as a
staff psychologist um where I would be
available to meet with students on an
as-needed basis and I was just going to
do it the other two days of the week
that I wasn't already previously
committed to my current practice um I
would have been paid hourly by UNH from
fees included in every student's tuition
not by individual clients or by
Insurance um I told my boss about the
opportunity how it could fill in my
available time while I continued to
build my client base her practice and
how I could even forward um potential
clients to her practice if they wanted
private Services as sometimes counseling
centers can get overwhelmed um and I
explained how it would not negatively
impact her business and it seemed to me
that it would only be a positive change
um my boss believed that it was in
conflict with my non-compete because it
meant providing Psychotherapy within the
30 mile radius and so was not okay with
my taking the job um I saw no conflict
my compete did not mention University
staff positions um also the clients
would be completely separate it was
drawing from an entirely different pool
of individuals um clients at UNH pay
nothing to be seen on campus and they
would have had to pay $150 a session to
be seen by me at the Private Practice um
and that fee is included in unh's
tuition um later that month she proposed
an alternate idea and that was to have
my boss contract my services out to UNH
so I would remain her employee so that
the income from my two days working on
campus would come from UNH into her
practice meaning my boss would take a
cut before I got paid um UNH and I were
both very unwilling to do that um and so
basically I decided I was ready to leave
to look for opportunities um and I hired
a lawyer to check to see like how how
stuck would I be if I tried to find a
job within 30 miles um and but the
lawyer that I hired um was not convinced
that she would not come after me if I
tried to work within the radius and she
had you know enough enough grounds to
probably be able to do so um given my
financial State I chose not to take the
risk and instead found something outside
so um so I now work in nashille I'm very
happy where I am but after finding that
new job I was commuting 50 miles each
way five days a week for work until I
moved my family again so um you know and
I like had a two-year-old at home at the
time and I was working long days and was
driving really far um all because my
boss had an issue with my trying I don't
know to make enough money and if it
meant that she wasn't taking a piece of
what I could get um so so um you know
and actually in this in this situation
um I don't know there's one more little
piece to it that like my boss also my
old boss also had an issue with how a
few of a few clients of mine wanted to
follow me um and you know even those
that had a long-term relationship with
me and I had you know helped
sufficiently I'm also um highly trained
in treating OCD and anxiety disorders
which is a pretty specialized um
especially OCD is a pretty specialized
um treatment group and so to I was
making a name for myself in Portsmith
and then to have to say Okay anybody
who's looking for me now I'm going to be
in
Nashua good luck making that drive um
you know so it it it really I think it
impacted you know the mental health of
some people there um you know as well
because I needed to essentially
prematurely stop treatment with clients
um you know and I I did my best to try
to find them other people you know I
don't think there were any concerns of
Abandonment but you know it meant that
she was making things really difficult
um and I if I had not had to move and go
so far away I could have found a
different place to work and continued
seeing those patients in that area um so
I don't know I mean I think this um you
know this bill won't actually even
directly affect me I know that it's not
going to be for retroactive ones and
that's fine I actually only even have
four months left on my non-compete
anyway um but it's still important
enough to me that other mental health
practitioners don't end up in this same
situation both for the practitioners but
also for the patients that they treat um
you know I mean we develop you know
sometimes really close um sometimes
life-saving relationships with patients
and it's really unfortunate that
sometimes if somebody's unhappy in their
job for what whatever reason um that
they need to end and you know they need
to sever those relationships um you know
is really pretty terrible so um you know
I think it's detrimental to patients if
their clinician is forced to move if
she's unhappy in her job um you know
Mental Health Services are limited
enough in our state and I feel like we
should not make it even more challenging
for people to get and continue their
care um you know unnecessary disruptions
in care could have been prevented if I
had not been held to my non-compete so
um that's basically the end of what I
have to say but I'll take any questions
if anybody has any for me so uh
representative Abramson has a
question uh thank you and for your
testimony thank you for taking my uh
question um I wonder if I know that some
businesses uh need to have non-competes
in order to be able to invest in a
professional in some way or to hire them
um I've faced non-competes and I I chose
not to sign them uh I wonder if there's
some way that we can put like a some
type of limitation or a buyout a
guaranteed buyout so that if someone's
facing an old non-compete that they're
they're guaranteed an ability to to just
buy out by paying a certain amount of
money as though they're kind of paying
the other person back because sometimes
the the uh the other party holding on to
the non-compete will say oh this was
much more valuable than anything I
suggested when we first signed the
contract words if it were I don't know
say a few thousand dollars or some some
amount that you that you were guaranteed
to be able to buy out of a
non-compete as a
professional I mean that would have made
my situation better you know I mean
um you know it's still and and I
understand I mean I I think this um you
know I don't know I mean you know it
certainly would have made a difference
for me because I probably would not have
moved my family again and I probably
would have stayed in the area if I could
have just you know gotten out of the
non- cohete um it's I don't know I guess
to me in my situation it was just it it
was
a a lame sounding statement but an
unfair advantage that my boss had um you
know and I I even had looked you know I
felt like I had looked into the
non-compete prior to signing it you know
wondering is this going to be able to be
held up and upon originally checking it
out I was like I don't know like I'm not
sure that she can keep me from doing my
job but apparently she can keep me from
doing my job um at least within a 30
mile radius
um okay great uh representative am has a
question Keith you have a
question yeah I just had a question I'm
gon to keep it short
um you read the contract and signed the
contract um I did you committed to the
contract correct yes it was a huge
mistake but I did thank
you okay um thank you very much Karen
and I have Daisy Cassidy already
promoted so Daisy if you just unmute you
can uh and turn your camera back on turn
your camera on we can see you
and camera
on okay there we go hi hello hi thanks
for being here um my name is Daisy C I'm
a licensed um independent clinical
social worker so I'm a therapist at a
group practice in Dover um about two
years ago I started working there and as
part of my employment agreement was
asked to sign a non-compete Clause um my
first thought upon reading it was how it
would potentially impact me personally I
would not be able to work at all for
between 6 months and two years depending
on how long I had been at the practice
within a 25 mile radius of Dover that
would mean that if I left my clients
would no longer be able to see me and I
could not work in places like Portsmith
do Rochester exitor New Market Durham or
Hampton which are some of the larger
cities or towns in the state and all
within reasonable driving distance of my
home in the process of thinking about
this bill and preparing to get support
for it I talked with therapists who had
signed non-compete and had to get
relicensed in another state or commute
up to an hour in order to avoid being
sued by their employers when they
decided to leave it is possible that
they could have prevailed in court if
they had been sued proving that it
placed undue hardship on their ability
to find employment however some may not
have been able to afford a lawyer or
were convinced that they would not win
so they decided to let it go or they
were intimidated by the prospect
prospect of being sued and as a result
felt unable to leave their current POS
positions despite a desire to do so some
of those people wanted to be here today
but could not because they were also
asked to sign non-disclosure statements
when they did leave or as part of a
settlement after contesting a
non-compete some of them who are
considering leaving the their current
practices are afraid their public
testimony would make their situations
more
precarious there is a larger more
important issue however beyond the unto
hard undo hardship C for therapists
should they decide to change employers
or relocate their
practices it is an ethical issue one
which concerns our professional
responsibilities toward the people we
serve I will I will speak to the nasw
code of ethics here since I am so a
social worker but all the other
professional groups including the
American Psychiatric and American
Psychological Association and the
American Counseling Association have
their own version of this
standard our number one ethical
responsibility is to the well-being of
our clients of course we also have
responsibilities to the in institutions
where we
work after all without the mental health
centers and practices that serve our
communities many of those clients would
not have access to treatment at
all however the ethical code demands
that a therapist's primary
responsibility be to the people who have
entrusted their most private lives to us
patients who have invested hours and
hours possibly years building a
relationship with their therapist so
that we can support them in making
positive change developing healthy
relationships healing from trauma and in
some cases staying
alive though there are many reasons why
patient and therapist may need to end
treatment to sever that relationship
unnecessarily is irresponsible and
unethical it is not a trivial thing to
make the decision to seek help from a
mental health professional for some it
may be a relationship of Last Resort in
the best case scenario a client has the
motivation and fortitude and is lucky
enough to find another therapist who is
a good match for them quickly and to
begin building trust in a new
relationship the worst case scenario is
that a suicidal client has an
interruption in care that proves
fatal I'm sure most of us here are aware
of the troubling state of mental health
care in New Hampshire the the vast
majority of mental illness in our state
and in the rest of the country still
goes untreated and not unlike in the
adjacent medical professions the longer
illnesses go unaddressed the more
expensive the treatment is likely to
become and the more damage may be done
to lives families and
communities yet weight list to get
treatment at Community Mental Health
Centers and private practices can be
months long this has only increased over
the last year and if predictions about
an impending Mental Health crisis come
true although some would argue there's
already one and there has been for a
long time finding timely care will be
even harder as of now I personally am
booked solid for the next two months and
have a weight list stretching into May
current clients are needing more
frequent appointments clients who had
switched to monthly monthly check-ins
are asking to be seen more frequently
again and therapists are having to turn
people away because they just don't have
room for anybody
new so in reality there is no danger of
New Hampshire Mental Health Centers and
group practices running out of business
there is however danger for those we
serve especially for people dealing with
severe mental illness we should not
limit the ability of therapists to
continue to see their existing clients
or their availability for those who are
still waiting to get
care that's all thank you great thank
you um sorry to do this to you but I I I
was little shocked when I realized what
this bill was really about and um the
only time I've actually really heard
about because I know we passed the
non-compete um over the years was the
the classic example the example that I
was whole years ago was that a lawyer
goes to work for a law office and they
spend you know they're promoting the
lawyer they're G he's an expert and this
whatever and they do a lot spend some
money help promoting that person and and
the lawyer gets a big Client List says
okay I'm leaving and now I want to go
start my own
practice and basically takes his clients
with
him so is would that be true for mental
health prevent that that your you know
an employer would spend money to help
promote you get help you build up a I
mean that that your list is your list
you know simply word in mouth or does
that your employer have a potential have
been the people came and found you
because of who you were working with and
now you're kind of taking their clients
you know yeah I mean I think Beyond
putting my me on the website and
printing out business cards I my my
practice has been built up based on word
of mouth and my abilities as in
professionalism
therapist okay fair enough alrighty
thank you very much um I have one other
person of AJ
Deonte oh he's I that's my husband I put
him on because I wasn't sure if I was
going to be able to make it so you can
take him off okay and and then Carrie uh
I uh you know
uh uh um has her hand back up again um
so I guess I'll just yeah yes yes Carrie
how can I help
you hi yeah I just wanted to um to Quick
respond to your question about you know
the lawy building up their um you know
client load and then and then taking
them to go um that that you know if if a
practice owner you know were worried
about that part that's a separate
document that's a non-solicitation so
they can say just you can't take your
people with you but a
non-compete is in in my in my reading of
it in my understanding of it um is more
about you can't then be a lawyer within
the 30 m radius of that right okay well
that helps that helps explain it to me a
little B yeah so the non so you can't
like take your people as the
non-solicitation um so actually in my
current job I was very clear um and they
they didn't ask me to sign one but I
would not have signed a non-compete
again and will never again but I was
okay signing you know like agreeing that
I won't take patients with me because
that could potentially you know harm the
practice although I'm I'm with Daisy on
this one that it's it's not likely there
are you know we've got clients coming
out of our ears you know um you know
we're up to our eyeballs in it whereas
we're in need of more mental health
practitioners so sorry that's all thank
you okay great thank you um my my wife
needs paper I think this
is okay thank you very much and I will
have no one else we will close the
public hearing on House Bill 165 and
thank you all for coming
in uh so we're hopelessly behind Connie
so I guess but of course it's good that
it's a Committee Member that we're
behind so we don't have to uh have an
awkward situation but uh uh we'll open
up the public hearing on what's our
what's our bill number here now 472 472
okay great thank you and uh I'll uh
invite you to uh testify thank you thank
you chair hunt and I think it's still
morning so good morning to my uh
Commerce colleagues for the record my
name is Constance van hton I am the
repres representative of Hillsboro 45
which is Manchester WS 101 and 12 which
encompasses the west side of Manchester
it's an honor today to introduce hbil
472 relative to retroactive denials of
previously paid claims that's kind of a
cumbersome uh list of words so I will
try my best to kind of boil it down a
tiny bit I do know that there are others
who are lined up behind me to testify um
hopefully they're still there because
these are people who are practitioners
who make appointments and hopefully
they've been able to stay on at any rate
on new hampsh Just A Brief History New
Hampshire law prohibiting insurers from
imposing the retroactive denial of a
claim previously paid to a health care
provider except in certain circumstances
was adopted back in 2002 in that law the
denial the retroactive denial had to be
within 18 months that's a year and a
half of the date of the payment of the
claim in 2018 the time restriction was
changed to 12 months still one year for
individual health plans and managed care
plans in the last Health house session a
bill HB
1484 did pass the house it reduced the
time period to six months stipulating
some exceptions to this time requirement
of course with the Advent of covid
though as with many other bills that
bill died on the table in the Senate
current law therefore still provides
that the time frame for retroactive
denial of such previously paid insurance
claims is 12 months 12 months one year
this means that a year after a health
care provider has rendered services in
good faith of course an insurance
company can deny the claim that's one
year later certainly the insurer
shouldn't have to pay a claim for which
it is not liable
however the insurance company which
itself often often has time limits
within which you must file your claim
should not take a year to determine that
a service was ineligible and take back
the reimbursement uh that it already
paid how difficult it must be for a
health care provider to recoup the costs
from a patient or another insurance
company a year later there are other
questions for example if an insurer paid
a claim an error she should it take a
year to figure it out we're often
talking here about large insurance
companies with the ability to to
backtrack and to do this and far less
time than one year another question is
it fair to the health care provider that
the insurance can basically dock future
payments to recoup the claim that was
incorrectly made after a year has passed
uh this is sometimes called the clawback
bill for that reason uh a year later
they can claw back or take back the
money that is rightful theirs this is
the insurance company about which I
speak it is rightfully theirs however
they're taking that money from payments
that are coming in a year later House
Bill 472 which is the bill before you
today is identical to hb1 1484 from the
last session it includes the shortened
six-month time requirement which in my
opinion is probably still too long it is
one of the results of discussions in
last sessions commission to study the
business environment for mental health
providers uh as I was waiting and
listening to the previous testimonies I
got an alert from NPR which says and I
quote mental health professionals warn
the pandemic may be raising suicide risk
for many kids representative abrami and
other speakers have alluded to the need
for Quality Health Care Health mental um
Health Care Providers including Mental
Health Providers and yet we are making
it very difficult for them to do the
jobs with their clients with their
patients because they are mired in
paperwork trying to take care of this
type of an issue um in closing I would
just like to I would be Remis to say
that there aren't a few issues that have
been pointed out to me by those who may
testify today they're minor issues and
can easily be dealt with uh I'll take
questions if need be I know I need to be
um cognizant of time because the chair
put me just before lunch uh and so I
will take questions however the the
healthcare providers who I hope are
still on will be able to deal much
better with the questions than I can
thank you very much for listening to me
today
okay uh so yeah uh let's see I do have
one other representative representative
Moran is uh if you're there you can
raise your
hand usually do reps first but then I
don't
see see your hand
um okay next up uh well I see a hand up
and so Heidi page so we'll have Heidi
page you're are
now welcome to the commer
committee I did I did I do it right
there there you go okay you just have to
unmute
yourself hi can you hear me now yep
great okay great uh thank you for
hearing my testimony
today um representative en hton I don't
I I think you did our this bill um much
Justice in how you introduce this um I
am Heidi paage I have a practice
providing mental health counseling my
practice is located in conquered and I
have been in private practice for 20
years now I'm here to speak on this bill
on behalf of clinicians United New
Hampshire we find that this uh these
clawbacks uh are a burden on small
business
practitioners do their due diligence in
obtaining patient benefits they see the
patient maybe for one visit or a series
of visits and they bill insurers based
on the information insurers gave them
then they get paid those claims that to
the insurance end of
story but then months or even years I've
seen in some cases payments
uh of these payments clinicians get hit
with retroactive
denials I'm not aware of any other
industry that pays vendors or
consultants in a sense and then turns
around and takes monies paid back due to
their
error clawbacks are done by withholding
payments on current patients we are
seeing this creates an onerous paperwork
and tracking nightmare any practices
especially if there are multiple
practitioners at a site my colleague
Sean Hassel is hopefully going to be
able to speak more on this
today with a six-month margin Health
insurers who have many more resources
than we than small businesses in New
Hampshire should be able to identify
mistakes we
prefer that in cases where they find
that another insurance was responsible
for the claims that they be limited to
six months as well as general claims
right now there is an exception in
the um in the law that is exception
number
2E that states that claims that are the
subject of an adjustment with a
different
insurer um can be pulled back to
Infinity there is no restriction if an
insurance company say in 2 years finds
that there was a different insurer
responsible they come after us they
don't for the insurance company that is
responsible it was responsible for
coverage at the time of the DAT of
service so we are asking
that that the time limit go from the 12
months to the six Monon margin and we
again we believe that these insurance
companies have the resources to and the
compu in order to be able to do this and
um that I would ask that the committee
also consider
exception e be eliminated which allows
for Infinity for the clawback of claims
and with that I'll take any
questions okay uh any questions yes
representative Fargo me
inquire thank you Mr
chair um a question that has been
bothering me is when they um when they
hold this money back on Old claims it
the air is usually on the insurance
providers side is that
correct yes they will um we obtain the
benefits from them they give us the
benefits and we see the client and
collect co-pays or deductibles in um
conjunctions with us is the patients
coverage and they pay us so there is no
alarm on our side our side to say that
something's wrong because we're getting
paid um as we're seeing the
clients followup for the question me
clarire so when this happens are is it
then your responsibility to go to the
patient to collect those
monies or I mean how how do you get the
reimbursement for what is rightfully um
yours as a
provider uh thank you for that question
um so yes the the idea is that we I if
there is another insurance that was
responsible at the time that we to get
the money from that insurance company
which causes um a need for a lot of
excess resources to go towards tracking
that company filing these claims um
retroactive Ive
claims and um in in some cases trying to
go after the client but um the client
have only seen us for let's say six
sessions and we haven't seen them for 18
months and it's very awkward to go back
to a client and now try to retract money
from them um often times um as much as
80% of these um clawbacks are just
written off by the um
clinician any other questions from
committee members thank you okay seeing
none thank you very very much your
testimony all right next is Deb Warner
Deb I'm going to promote you to
panelist and you just have to unmute
yourself
Deb there you
are there we are thank you thank you
very much much it is a um an honor to be
uh testifying at your committee and
greetings to you chairman hunt and the
rest of the committee and thank you very
much um representative Connie uh van
hton for bringing this bill forward I
did send testimony and it if you look in
your email um my email address is Warner
608c it often goes to spam filters if
you could fish it out of there that'd be
lovely and uh see my thing I have um
personal experience with this issue with
clawbacks and I was completely surprised
I've always had a very sound practice
and I do my submissions very carefully
making sure that I've honored all of the
authorization requirements and such um
however I I have two sides of this
experience to tell tell you about and
one is I think you're aware um my
husband who is a retired legislator from
New Hampshire honorable member of the
Congress committee and he um as you know
several you are aware and in fact thank
you very much the three years ago he was
stricken with a complete paralysis after
a flu shot and was in Boston hospitals
for much of year of 2018 I was down
there with him much of that time thank
thank you people for prayers and good
wishes during that time and he's still
improving and getting better and uh we
learned a lot from the experience it was
very um touching how many people showed
care and how we learned even more about
our love for each other and our need for
prayer and um we developed an intense
respect for the medical profession uh
even being part of it already myself I
we just were amazed at the things people
did we also were grateful to have
insurance coverage and how it covered
this entire uh episode which was a lot
of money uh being in intensive care and
such all over Boston um there were
people at the insurance company who were
very helpful advocates for us in the
admissions process and such they they
they went overboard and did great
things unfortunately even as late as
last year which like two more than two
years after the episodes of care we were
subject to clawbacks for that care and
many thousand dollars like
$177,000 and $4,000 and all over the
place there were still clawbacks going
on in that care and certainly that was
not the the major part of what had been
paid thank goodness they didn't pull
back the bar big Parts but still that
kind of money is a huge amount of money
for us especially I wasn't working much
I was following Mike to Boston and um
was out of employment at the moment at
that time he he was um couldn't work so
that was you know over
$20,000 That Came Upon Us uh from these
Boston hospitals and still to this day
every month I spend a day on the phone
with the insurance companies and the
hospitals and still trying to metal this
out this is from the patient
side from the provider's side as a
doctor I um received clawbacks just
before Mike went in the hospital I was
stricken with clawbacks that reached
back 20
months and it was there were so many
errors in them and it was just so
impossible
they ended up taking these clawbacks
from future payments of future patients
and there was no way to figure out where
it was how it happened this was many
thousands of dollars because the
insurance company had suddenly decided
that they were going to uh use a um
discount for teley medicine and they
were going to apply this
retroactively for patients who had
received care and um it was very
dramatic in my budget my cash flow and
my business went really badly at that
point all the same time that Mike's in
the hospital it was a very difficult
time um I consulted with my billing um
people who submit these things for me n
nobody could figure it out and the the
company that I use is a multinational
company it's not like we they have no uh
sophistication at all and um still to
this day there those years that those
were affected I could not close the
books on that account I had to climb
through and I I managed to finally
figure out through this sweeping swirl
of
misaligned paperwork that was sent to me
and
un um referenced deductions from future
payments that I finally did get some of
it and I figured out where the mistakes
were made but by then I I couldn't go
back to the insurance this is now three
years later to be able to go back to the
insurance companies and
uh appeal that was it's gone this is
much money gone so uh I just wanted to
share with you the impact of a long
drawn out clawback
reach and how it hits a both a consumer
and a provider and it's uh very dire so
I do support this bill and I appreciate
that it's been brought forward I'll take
any
questions um I don't see any so but
thank you and it's nice to see you
again uh so Sean has I don't have you on
my list but I know you were mentioned in
your in your hands up so I will let you
speak here but um
anyway you just have to unmute yourself
[Music]
John hi there can you hear me yes good
okay thank you very much uh uh chairman
hunt and uh thank you for having me I
had originally registered and when was
unable to make it but then the system
didn't allow me to change my status to
want to testify so they told me that if
I just raised my hand that maybe there
would be that chance so I appreciate um
you allowing me this chance and thank
you to Representative members of um
Commerce Committee for all you do and
for hearing this today um I'm calling to
uh talk a bit about retroactive denials
and how they impact in this case um
group practices so um individual
practitioners um are hit very hard by
these um and I really um do appreciate
representative en hooton and the other
two people who testified in terms of
their description of retroactive denials
um and how they really do hurt uh small
businesses um and I just urge everybody
to remember that during this time
there's been references to there being a
mental health crisis uh today right now
uh Co having worse into that and uh to
please consider how these small business
and often if it's individual
practitioners sort of micro businesses
can be very very hard hit uh in terms of
impact on on on finances um um I co-own
a group um group Psychotherapy family
therapy practice in we have offices in
Manchester and Salem it's 11 providers
total um in the two regions um and I
thought I would just describe
um some put some some numbers on it
because at our practice we've actually
tracked you know how this has happened
over time so if you go back uh this is
only counting clawbacks or retroactive
denials that are too $50 are over we
have more frequent smaller ones um but
in our experience those are a bit more
manageable to be able to track down and
if it's just say two sessions or three
sessions and maybe only three or five
months after Services we're pretty
successful at getting those but I'm
talking sort of um larger uh clawbacks
retroactive denials um so the uh if we
go back over the course of our history
we started in 2009 it's uh 28 total
retroactive denials of that size or
larger so it's not a enormous amount
each year but the work involved is
something that I'm wanting to emphasize
today and the impact financially can be
quite large so they have average those
$670 each so some are smaller you know
three four $500 others we've had retro
we've had retroactive denials amounting
to2 $3,000 a couple of times um the
total of those uh 28 is
$18,750 that hit that we've been hit
with at our group practice um and then
following up on that with extensive
Outreach on our part reaching out trying
to ascertain was there another insurance
that should have been primary for
example or another responsible party and
trying to reach out to clients many of
whom are
terminated um we've been able to get
back
6,140 so that has left us with a net
nearly
$113,000 um over a period of time most
of that by the way more of those
retroactive denials I don't know why
they accelerated starting in 2016 so
more of them have been since
2016 I want to speak a little bit to uh
representative Fargo you had a um some
questions about this and yes absolutely
most often the the error has been on the
Insurance's part every once in a while
it's a shared responsibility with the
client we sometimes at our group have
had clients that don't they fail to
mention they have another insurance and
they don't know that that other
insurance is the primary one and so we
verify benefits and we ascertain that
there are there is indeed coverage we
start billing and the error that the
insurance makes is they pay it and then
they only later learn you know maybe and
and and I have to say it is particularly
difficult when it goes beyond six months
when when the services were rendered and
finished up six seven eight nine months
12 months prior um it's not only a
financial burden the administrative
burden is enormous um each one of these
retroactive denials in my experience to
sort of troubleshoot and try to find
what really went on and then you're
trying to reach if you if you imagine if
you will will you you're trying to reach
a client who often has finished up
services a year prior and at the time
they thought it was all fine it was all
being paid because their insurance paid
it and now they're gone and we have to
reach out to them if if it indeed is
their responsibility or to at least
ascertain is there another insurance if
that's the issue
sometimes they work with us sometimes
they don't but often we don't succeed in
getting those monies back and I'm part
of a group and we have some resources
for that compared to an individual
practitioner and even for us it's often
quite overwhelming and the time involved
in in each one of these retroactive
denials we're talking two three four
I've spent up to six hours on one
retroactive denial so you can imagine an
hourly an already not great
reimbursement rate from insurance
carriers then gets watered down water
down water down so if if if you know in
this case I'm often the one who chases
them so if I'm on when I say four five
six hours it's calling the insurance
company being on hold as everybody knows
happens now I I've been on hold recently
for insurance companies it's been really
bad the last month I'm talking hour hour
and a half on hold with Anthony lacrosse
for example um and then it's trying to
talk with um Insurance reps trying to
find out what exactly happened how come
they paid and then what are they saying
was the primary insurance if there was
another Insurance uh and then it's uh
sometimes we actually another thing
represented Fargo to to add to that we
have more than one found that the
insurance more than one time found the
insurance is actually incorrect there
was not another Insurance maybe the
family started another policy but never
paid for it but somehow in the systems
it looks like them to them like there
should have been another insurance that
paid I have to chase it town talk with
the family the family says no we never
even paid for that other policy it takes
and then then you're on the phone and
sometimes you have to elevate it to a
supervisor I mean just the
administrative burden alone is enormous
um enough so that it often feels like
it's sort of Geared for us to just give
up and write it off and we we we do we
we often end up having to write off you
know each year we we write off a few
thousand dollars because of this um so
um I guess I just wanted to emphasize
those pieces and that this particular
Bill the pieces that are helpful is that
it would shorten it to six months as the
default 12 it is very clear to us the
insurance should have the internal
resources um Heidi page testified to to
that being uh the experience that you
know they they have internal resources
to be able to do this in Far sooner than
a year um and if you can keep in mind if
they can let us know that there's been
an error on their part and they paid
incorrectly and it's four months often
we're still with the client or we can
reach the client we can apply more
leverage it may not be so difficult and
we're willing to do that work but it's
when it's many many months later and a
lot lot of these retroactive denials
come in the six to 12 month range um I
agreed with um Heidi PA's testimony that
there is one part of this bill it's to
it's the exception to e um that you know
I feel should be eliminated altogether
if it goes beyond six months and they
find that there should should have been
another insurance that was primary um
really at this point they have better
resources and we're not in a place if
anybody here by the way wonders well if
the if the end it's client
responsibility like you should have it
set up and indeed in our informed
consent we have it set up that we
reserve the right to say report them to
collections but I just want to make sure
all the representatives on this
committee know that any mental health
provider who's really thinking about it
and attending ethics conferences and
workshops knows that it is folly to
report a client to collections because
it is not at all uncommon that they
would do a spous report of alleged
misconduct to the board of mental health
just because they're ferious that we're
reporting them to collections uh it also
it it it flies in the face of our code
of ethics to be able to do something
like that when we know many of them are
not even going to have the money to pay
say $1,200 bill that they thought was
already covered a year after Services
ended so it is just um it's just not an
option for us so it leaves the provider
really the way it is right now with clax
it leaves the provider holding all the
responsibility all the burden of the
time time involved and often out the
money for services rendered you know at
the time you know so I guess I'll leave
it at that and I'm open to any questions
that um people might
have any questions the
committee seeing none well thank you
very much for your testimony we
appreciate it thank you uh so Marcy I've
already promoted you so you're you're
on hi I'm um Good Good afternoon
chairman hunt and committee members um
I'm here to speak in support of
472 uh which you're considering in this
committee meeting I'm a licensed
independent clinical social worker and
and I have a small Private Practice in
New Market um and I wanted to provide an
example of how practices by insurance
companies can have impact on small
business um when I started this uh
practice it had been really important to
me to to support our military and I
volunteered for years with New Hampshire
debart working with National Guard
members and their families and when I
opened my practice as a solo
practitioner I became enrolled in the
tri care Tri care insurance uh company
in order to be able to provide treatment
for veterans and active duty families at
the end of 2013 I received a letter from
that insurance company that they
conducted a retroactive audit of a
client's account who I'd stopped seeing
over a year and a half ago demanding
that I repay close to $1,000 despite the
P the fact that I'd submitted claims
correctly and had been given regular
authoriz I ations from them for
treatment based on medical needs and I I
sat in at the tail end of one of your uh
committee hearings on prior
authorizations and in this particular
case um they' given prior authorizations
for this client every 12 12 weeks for
services um when I called the in in the
New Hampshire insurance company at that
time I was told that there wasn't any at
the time there was no law or rule that
regulated how F how far back insurance
companies could go I know that since
it's since then there have been a couple
pieces of legislation that have taken it
back to 18 months and then to 12 months
um I'm and I I I still think that that's
too long um as a small business owner
that represented a sign this represented
a really significant payment to me um I
sent a letter of appeal as it seemed
really unfair that they'd certify
eligibility every 12 weeks and then a
year and a half after the client's case
had closed uh go back and tell me that I
owed money from claims that were three
years old based on um the information
that I'd submitted and the claims were
correct they told me the client wasn't
eligible for service and they were going
to begin recouping um the money from
future claims well at that time I
stopped taking Tri trie clients and
finally in 2015 I was contacted by their
legal department and um they offered me
to to file a good CLA good Clause waiver
good claim good cause waiver um around
that um which hadn't been offered to me
at the first time when I appealed it
they said there was no appeal so um I
recognize that this legislation wouldn't
apply to Tri care but at the time that
this happened I had multiple um
practitioners that I met with and in our
practice were required to consult 40
hours um a year a licensing period with
with peers and we meet regularly um and
I just in the small group that I met
with there were many uh peers who had
had similar circumstances with private
insurers it doesn't make sense to me
that as a a small business owner I have
to submit claims from many insurance
companies within six months in order to
be paid and some even within three
months but companies can do a
retroactive audit on a client and go
back 12 months requiring clinicians to
pay money back when the error wasn't the
error of the
therapist um I know as Sean mentioned
researching those claims is really
difficult uh particularly for a small
business owner solo practitioner
um I'd recommend that the insurance
companies be held to the same standards
that they hold practitioners to in terms
of being being able to build for
services um so in insurance companies as
Sean mentioned have a huge staff um who
are regularly review claims um and so if
we have to submit those claims or risk
non-payment within six or three months
insurance company should have to do the
same thing um it's not uncommon for
clients seeking treat treatment from
from my office as other people have
mentioned to report a three or more
month wait for the Community Mental
Health Center for services I know that
other legislation's been passed to to um
has been filed to address the scarcity
of mental health practitioners in the
state and I know that right now there
are clients that I turn away every week
I have a small practice and I'm doing
primarily teleah health because of the
pandemic uh but even still we I'm
finding that there are many more people
that need the support of mental health
treatment at this point
this regulation as it's written
discourages small business owners from
coming into the field and I really urge
you to support this bill and I want to
thank you for your consideration and
allowing me to speak on
it thank
you very much um all right so I do have
some names but I don't see them here
listed so I guess I'll I guess that be
this is a little daring but um if if uh
if you're an attendee and and you were
signed up to speak or wanted to speak
please uh raise your hand
and uh I'll promote
you
uh okay oh here oh Don fonstein okay Don
uh and who are you representing today
Don you have to unmute
yourself there you
go I'm on
audio yes you are oh okay um you could
turn your camera on too if you had keep
but I don't know maybe I yeah I promoted
you but I had a hard time okay no no
problem so who do you representing here
here we go hi there he is okay I uh for
the reckon my name is Don fonstein and
um I work with Heidi Coral we represent
ahip here in New Hampshire
I uh vaguely remember this bill um I
think it was back in January or February
before the pandemic hit last last
session
and I you know I I I know actually my uh
peer uh Paula Rogers has actually been
very involved in the issue as well but
my sense really
is are we going to
continually rewrite the insurance code
the statutes to deal with what
is admittedly uh a very uh sympathetic
but
small um uh component of the of the
provider Community which which last year
and from when I was able to hear this
today um seems to still be the case and
and and really that's that's really the
only point I wanted to share with the
committee and with that I'd be happy to
be quiet or answer any questions if
someone is so
inclined okay
great uh representative AEL has a
question if you were willing to take
one go ahead representative able yes
thank you for for testifying um what are
the uh main reasons
insurance
companies
uh uh do clawbacks or requests to be
reimbursed uh for those of us who aren't
in you know aren't in the business uh it
would be helpful to know what kinds
of uh mistakes uh you find that re that
cause this to happen are you able to to
uh give us some examples I I uh I'm sure
the planers can do a better job
but the probably the the the most
obvious
one uh to uh understand would simply be
when there is no
coverage uh if if there's no coverage on
the data
service
um then you shouldn't have a
situation where you by Statute or
otherwise are encouraging someone to pay
a bill that's not justly
owed um
with that I guess I I would say that
alone would be a reason why you would be
cautious um uh before you
expand um what has been done um in the
recent
past yeah I would say is I I know that I
often get when you have doing claims and
stuff um a question to see whether it
really should have been covered under
workers comp rather than your health
insurance that's the one I know of but
uh representative Terry has a
question sir were you on uh when we uh
heard the testimony from Dr
Warner uh unfortunately I was not I
tried to get on but for some reason it
was not allowing me in she related to us
an experience where um she claims that
uh clawbacks were oh Excuse excuse me
representative do do you do you mean the
doctor or provider that was speaking
immediately prior
yeah I I did I did hear I did hear that
she she described a scenario hear what
his question is first on thank you Mr
chairman uh she indicated that the
clawbacks uh went back as far as two
years I think she mentioned something in
the area of 17 to
$20,000 uh she did not provide us with
details but was speaking about primarily
about the time frame involved uh do do
you know why uh
clawbacks um should be uh going on two
years to
Infinity um I I can't tell you I I'm
aware of one uh similar to what you
described but I I will tell you sometime
and I'm not suggesting this was the case
certainly with with with a provider but
um oftentimes insurance fraud is
difficult uh uh uh to discover and to be
able to prove so certainly that would be
one example where you would have uh a a
Long Reach back I mean clearly
clearly the the the the story that um uh
the provider
described uh you know at some level
starts to shock the conscious
consciousness and and uh you know in the
absence of fraud or in the a in the
absence of some intentional misconduct
that doesn't rise to that level then
then you should have you should have uh
a bar against that long a lookout and I
and I think clearly I mean the law right
now has been updated so that wouldn't be
the case the story she described I think
she said would would would not be
allowed to happen today
further question represent you you muted
yourself so I guess
yeah thank you for a followup so you do
believe that some sort of time frame is
reasonable I think we've made one that
may be reasonable so the answer is yes
yeah the current law is a year the aners
the ansers is I I personally think
current law makes sense but I
mean if you ask me if I think three
years is is appropriate no I didn't ask
ask you if you saw any time frame was
reasonable so thank you okay uh
representative Bartlett has a question
thanks very much um I have to say Mr
um um finstein that you're not coming
across very sympathetically to me um yes
we changed it to 12 months after hearing
many of these kinds of cases um in the
last couple of
years
because I mean do you think that it's
reasonable for the insurance companies
to require providers to bill in in
within three months but you think you
think that 12 months is still a
reasonable amount of time to claw back
if you find something wrong yes
yes okay thank
you all right uh okay is there anyone
else who would like to testify on this
bill going once going
twice okay so we'll end the public
hearing on House Bill
472 and uh I am now officially we're
going to let everybody have a lunch
break and get stretch your legs and
we'll meet back here at
1:15 and just so you know the computer
is we're going to continue to record so
you want to make sure you turn off your
mic and camera so and I guess
is the it be the smart thing to do Mr
chairman I have a question yes it be
easier if we logged off and log back in
you could do that too okay thank
you okay did I do that right
Pam you still around Pam I am still here
I you're the screen's jumping around so
I missed my button can't see you where
are you right it's hard to get that um
yeah that was that was um perfect okay
point of right you're GNA put up on the
little note there that that we're out to
lunch right I am I'm I'm closing a bunch
of documents on my computer so I can
find it quickly so no I this's my desk
and I don't leave papers here um so okay
it'll be up in a sec all right no
problem I will see you at 150
I'll be back I'll be
back
hey chairman hunt yes representative
Wesson how are you I'm good thank you uh
just warmed up a little bit I was cold
um how could you go over the blue sheets
on the last couple bills when you have a
chance I could have but they were four
pages long but they're supposed to be
giving you a total of opposed in
supports if you could just give the
totals that would be
great okay I could do that so on
472 it was 223 in support eight opposed
one
neutral wait could you do that again
223 in the green
y eight in the
red
posed then and then of course Tyler is
neutral oh yeah all right thank you you
very much yeah I I mean I could have
gone through but I think even just
mentioning that it's a I should have you
I was just I was more conscious of my
time but I will do that in the future
that when I don't list him I'll give the
numbers thank you you're
welcome representative hunt yes hi Don
yes um I saw the
um meeting for today
yes um I I have a little problem I have
a big school board meeting at 6:30
tonight all right well we hope to be
quick okay I wasn't sure I just wanted
to let you know I just because of
they're bringing up S sp20 and I want to
be on there so that I can have
representation and support of it because
I know they don't support
it really okay yeah the school board is
not why would they take a
position yeah I my I always ask the
question if it's best for the kids why
wouldn't we do it right and that's the
first and foremost question in
everything I do when it comes to my
school board and so I want to be there
to and I've got um information that I
can use to help back up everything so I
just wanted to let you know that if I
scoot out if we're not done you know why
yep no problem okay thank
you no
problem
okay
love your helper Anita I know he's my
executive
assistant push his paper for you oh yeah
right off the
desk John yeah it was called to my
attention that you didn't read the blue
sheet Joyce already gave me a hard time
um Joyce is good at that I like that
about so um not withstanding
that uh half the people who were signed
up to speak didn't speak which well we
ran late though that's hard when
somebody has that was that was probably
just as well but yes there were
223 people who signed up in support 223
in support how many against eight eight
I'll have to get to
them right I have to say that the uh
Insurance um those who were testifying
on behalf of the insurance companies
didn't come across very sympathetically
no that was best F fun scene he and I go
way back he he actually
um how long to go back this
is literally back in
19 John John just to let you know my
screen says we're being recorded yes we
are just so that you know oh yes okay
Don and I go back in
1980 and which in which um Arie Arison
was on the committee and she she
insisted that when we had the indoor
smoking act she insisted to uh Fraser
who was the chair that I chair the
subcommittee of that bill and uh and Don
uh represented um businesses who are
going to be affected by the indoor
smoking act and uh so we we I known each
other known each other a very long time
and uh so so when he got on there I go
oh this is not going to be
good because you know he's he's filling
in with Heidi he's filling in for
another Lobby so he's not totally up to
speed and right and you know Heidi did a
good job I don't necessarily agree with
her but I she always she's always
prepared yeah she does and it didn't
feel like he was Don Don had no business
W it at
all but you know it's okay so you know
like I say Don and I go way back so I of
all the respect in the world for him but
uh and he's you know represents his
clients well but um there are time when
it comes to these Health bills I don't
know how anybody any lobbyist can say oh
yeah sure I can stand in for you because
the nuances and elements of it is just
overwhelming sometimes yeah it's really
true yeah but even the word and thank
goodness we've got Tyler oh yeah and
we're very I read some of these things
20 times and I think what did it say
and fortunately Tyler's you know last
one standing he's still around I we yeah
a lot of change over there at the it
sure
has so okay all right so what's looks
like time to open up the hearing and um
yes this is one of those where I am
sponsoring it for the department so I I
would ask the department to introduce
the bill even though they would really
love me to do it but I just assume have
them do it so um who who's here from the
Department okay there we go all
right good afternoon
Heather you just have to unmute
yourself can you hear me now there you
go perfect yeah I literally lost you
just as you were about to try to get me
so that happen
sometimes so um my name is Heather
Silverstein I'm general counsel the for
the insurance department uh this bill uh
the HB 519 is a technical bill and it's
trying to tidy up some of our insurance
statutes um Marty had uh Moy our legal
coordinator had submitted written
testimony I believe yesterday to the to
the committee um I can touch on some of
the highlight lights if you'd like me to
I'm yeah I think you should I think you
should go through okay so there's like
eight different things and really it is
truly technical um there were no
surprises to Industry they're supportive
of this bill uh the first two regard
relate to record retention one inside
the department and one for industry the
um our record retention has been a
really long time it's been like a full
six years so we're we decreasing that to
a full three years it's long overdue uh
some agencies don't even have a record
retention statute so uh we're just
trying to get up to speed with not
having so much paper around and even
electronic data and um so that's the
first one the second one deals with a um
underwriting file for companies and just
making sure that they're keeping uh it
is required by law for them to keep a
declination notice so that's just
clarifying that up in the statute
there's some confusion The Way It Was
Written
um the other statute uh the next one
deals with mergers of
companies and this was based on an um an
Old neic National Association of
insurance Commissioners model so our
statute was based on an old model that
really made no sense as far as the
timing goes uh because we don't have
control over when the merger is
finalized even if we approve it so that
date used to be based off that it made
no sense so we're just putting in after
we have the hearing at the department
the commissioner has to decide within 30
days so uh and that's getting more up to
speed what what other states in New
England or have done and have recognized
it's a it's a it's a timeline that makes
no sense so we're trying to make some
sense there um there's another um change
in the Dead line for holding companies
so right now the statute requires May
one again the neic the National
Association of insurance Commissioners
they don't even look at this information
um once the department has received it
until like late fall so it's helping our
it's helping our lenses and it's helping
our staff as well because they have a
very busy filing uh season in the spring
and to kind of spread that out these
filings that have to be submitted by the
companies so moving that from May 1 to
August one is really helpful for really
everybody involved um we we actually um
it was
particularly uh noticed
last last spring during the
pandemic when there was companies that
were having trouble so um that's what
that's doing there was a typo in the in
the um PBM law the 402 N5 it referred to
the it was supposed to refer to
paragraph one instead it referred to um
a preceding um 402 N4 it made no sense
so again we're fixing a typo in that
statute um in the Life settlement
statute
408d um we're adding solicits because
that's actually what the definition
within that same stat statute talks
about for life insurance uh life
settlement producers they solicit or and
negotiate that's in the definitions it's
also in our typical our general producer
statute U would talk about soliciting or
negotiating so we're tidying that up in
that particular part of the the statute
d35a and then uh two the last two uh one
is just um getting our terms consistent
with what's not what industry
recognizes and so like changing to life
coverage an annuity
contract uh so that we're not using
terms that are not up toate in our
statutes and then the last one is 415 um
6n um dealing with the children's early
intervention there was supposed to be a
reference to the ACA last year I'm I had
discussions with Tyler about this he
just said it was was inadvertently like
left out and so that's what we're doing
we're just including the reference that
should have been there before so and
that's
everything happy to take any questions
that you
have any questions from
anybody nothing
anybody else would like
to okay so this we're
doing
and what I have for my sheets for
um okay uh so is Marty not gonna be
around is she testifying see around no
Marty's out today okay okay snow
day okay all right uh is there anybody
else anybody else who would like to
testify on the attendees oh we do have a
hand up okay great promote panels
Chris Claver clear oh that's
Chris why is he why is he over in
attendees okay who
knows M mcair has been coming in as an
attendee and I'm not sure why I've been
promoting him oh I see you promoting him
okay in the past I will and then you
have to rename them
too
okay all right there he is yeah so you
got now we got to get that was my
question I wasn't I wasn't getting in oh
you're the echoing yeah you get two two
deves
on can't do that yeah so whenever you do
two devices you want to always make sure
you turn one of them sound off but okay
all right so is there anybody else who
would like to testify on this
bill I guess not so we'll close the
public hearing on
519 too
easy I didn't take that one through how
much time I give on that
I way too much time
okay um so just give you a little up up
to dates uh so we are scheduling uh for
um next Monday and T excuse me next
Tuesday and
Wednesday and then Wednesday at 1:15 you
know the uh hour um executing hour where
have scheduled like this like tomorrow
we're having exact at 1:15 um I I was
going to uh take on the bill bills so we
heard the first
day we can discuss those bills um and
and chrisy I'll talk to you touch base
with you so that you know where what I'm
thinking and then we can you can get
back and your people and my people and
we can see how we do um but I would
emphasize to everyone especially after
today any of these bills that are going
to need amendments that really need time
uh we're just going to have to retain I
just I just don't feel we can do justice
to them um without without spending a
little time and really working on them
and making sure we we get it right um
well I think we' um all acknowledged
that we've had a couple of surprises
things that we thought were going to be
simple aren't going to be simple right
right and we'll just have to work on
them yeah and I just it just seems you
know makes sense that you know we'll
just put things off till the fall and
then we can it'll mean we'll have a
busier fall I guess you know but well
depends on where we are in the fall
this ha to travel
some people want Trav right we'll have
to figure out to schedule that in but at
least we're not at least it's not an
election year so we'll be right time to
to work on it but I was just gonna say
this last bill um that Heather just
presented I am so glad I do not have to
read through insurance law anymore my
gosh that's dry as a bone I have to say
really well some it's really some of the
oldest statutes too yeah I'm glad
they're doing it it needed to be done
we've had a number of bills that cleaned
up a lot of old language and I think
that came from the previous insurance
commissioner wasn't it the one that was
there for a short time John Ellis was
one of his
um yeah well he we did well we did a lot
of lot of re recodification going
through the same with banking but I
think that there are urged to do that
through internal what we call that
internal the uh inspector whatever
general or that they PR them to
yeah get their statutes up to date and
more compliance but the insurance
department has been as much as you know
a problem because they have Nic really
govering well any see can help them a
lot but you know it at least steer them
in the right direction
yeah but it's probably not things I
would have taken on unless
prodded excuse me Mr chairman can I just
do a little bit of business while we're
um in between um representative
melier is that the correct pronunciation
I hope it
isier um Chris you're on mute so yes
that's that's correct okay Maier could
and the reason I had two on is that I
wasn't getting my picture up there so I
put another one on I thought it was my
mistake right my question for you is
I've noticed that you come in um as an
attendee rather than using your personal
link and that's why you keep having that
problem you come in on the public link
rather than
your personal one and I'm wondering if
you're not getting it I'm sending it to
a private email address not your
legislative address okay all right
you're right I'm putting in my
legislative address I'll put in the
other address from now on okay I get it
would you get that just before an hour
to be the meeting you get this that
thing from call it what HCS or it is
that writing and and you just click on
that one that that gets you in as who
you are but I can send it to your
legislative address if you prefer it's
it's all would you please do that I will
change the address and then then that we
should be it should be much smoother for
you every day thank you and Chris you
should tell the house clerk's office
that you prefer to have your personal
address used because it needs to be
consistent i' I've asked no I prefer not
to have my personal address I prefer to
have my leg
oh then well then maybe you need to tell
them is that what's listed on your on
your um when you go into the New
Hampshire general court and you pull up
me uh House of Representatives and
members what does it show for your
address on there I'll I'll I'll have to
go check that out okay and just so
everybody knows I the original address
that I used for all of your accounts was
what was posted on the website but then
I know some people changed that address
and I didn't get change of address
notice so so that could be the
explanation that that representative
Maier at one point had his personal
address and and then asked it to be
changed but I didn't recheck everybody's
addresses right so this is the first
time that that's that's happened every
other time I've been able to get up up
there thank you okay well um it'll be
your legislative address from this day
forward so we'll stick with that thank
you yeah I I I never got a legislative
address I I just figured one one more
email address was going to be a
nightmare for me um you know as it is
um I have I have a Gmail account which I
don't tell anybody except if I have
problems with my Prodigy
account how about you John how many
emails do you have
um four four possible yeah possible but
I only use Comcast for my regular and my
ledge mail for this stuff uh I've
already had a a good dis conversation
about which mail I can use to get to
what emails because in order for me to
do this it it comes in on my ledge mail
I forward it to my regular email then I
go up to Comcast and put it in one my
one of my file folders in Xfinity and
like that I can use on my on my laptop
toop
right so this is not easy for me that
seems right labor intensive but also um
so now of course I'm a Mac User and not
and I haven't really done PC on mail but
I assume you pretty much all the
features are the same so one of the
things that I I I've been doing so I
thought I'd pass this along to everybody
then when you get uh people's
presentation when they their testimony
and stuff what happens is when they
register to sign up they at the same
time can upload their their um their
speech when that speech gets sent it
immediately gets emailed to your email
address so what I was what I have been
doing and I'm just passing it on is that
I have color code I had color flags on
my Mac and I assume PC has color Flags
or something like that where so now I've
just chose a color and I just and and so
I I flag all those so that if I ever
need to go back and look for
testimonies it would all be in one be
one sort rather than trying to stick it
in a folder I just use that flag feature
so is that is there one of you guys a PC
user does PCS have the have the flag I I
I print it out and put it in my trusty
4inch binder well
that's that's old school that I ain't
doing F I'm not a
futer my my computer is my file box
that's you know when I tell people I
said you better off sending me an
invoice or sending me just email it to
me and I can find it faster on my by
searching on my my mailbox and I can
printing it out and filing it or
whatever I might I may not doing with it
but
so okay uh so the next
bill is
that 145 45 and represented MCB we have
oh great represa another former member
of
committee is representative Weston still
with
us yes she's there she's just got her
camera off yeah I'm
here hi I'm wearing a a ski
tie today just just in honor of all the
snow that we got downhill yeah I figured
you would get a kick out of this
one I'm going on Thursday there you go
I'm so jealous will be out you going up
to Canon yeah yeah gonna be pretty nice
I'm so
jealous so Chris do you have your hand
up did you wna yeah we you were
discussing organizational things uh and
I my question is uh with your
legislative mail
email uh can you create folders in that
in that email because I don't I don't
really know how to do that because so so
all my
Commerce stuff will go into a folder
because I that legislative email is 90%
junk and it just adds up uh so
quickly catch getting junk in your
legislative email no it's just it's just
so okay are you being sarcastic no I
saying I I although I'm so glad I don't
do do that that way but I didn't realize
they would get junk by that I I was just
looking for something that would uh a
folder that I could uh are you a Mac it
would automatically go into a folder
yeah are you a Mac person or a PC person
what do you have uh it's it's a p uh I'm
a PC person not windows but Firefox
right you blocking the junk my huh you
can block the junk so that somebody
doesn't keep sending
it no I just find most of the content is
junk so I uh can block the user that's
another story you know go it says says
you know I had to turn my junk off
because I my constituents would show up
in the junk file I mean I that I was
having I don't know it was I I could I I
got rid of it because I mean spam folder
we I get email from Ethiopian princes
telling me I've won the
oh I haven't gotten those right but but
is the answer yes that I can actually
create a folder in legislative email oh
yes I I have many folders on your
computer on your on your mail on your
mail program what's what what mail
software program are you using to read
your mail with I don't know it's
Microsoft Mail Microsoft Mail yeah or
Outlook was it it called Outlook uh yeah
I
uh I I use Gmail I don't know what uh
Gmail you're logging into their web page
you know that what you want what you
want to be doing mean you're maybe
you're not doing is that you want to use
Outlook or use a mail
program words I'm I'm you know apple is
called first class mail but and but then
Microsoft had an Outlook program for the
Macintosh but Outlook is the is am I
right Outlook is the is the yeah program
for for for Microsoft Office I mean you
have Microsoft Office Chris yes that's
what that's what
we yeah I know that they used to charge
extra for Outlook I know it was more
expensive to get that but um you know
that's the mail program in which yeah
you can put in things in folders and
organize your your different emails
address addresses so my legislative
email I can I I have to go to Outlook or
someplace like that right well other
words like I I'm using my Apple mail so
on it I have all my different email
address
addesses and and then I have my and then
below it is folders and you can drag
things and put them in folders or um you
know you can or I when I like I say I I
put I do Flags because flags are kind of
nifty just hit the color and and up Pops
all my I don't know I just uh I don't I
don't have folders anywhere but in my uh
social Med you got to use a mail program
you need a mail program so um I you know
if you're if you're using a PC based
machine if you're using do you use Word
Microsoft Word and
Excel I don't use Excel I use word you
know as long as it's English I use it
well no they got translators too you
know well Microsoft Word Outlook works
with word so you can you can do
something like mail merge and with
Outlook you'll have all your you all you
put your everybody in there your mail
and you can send out and print labels
for Christmas cards and and you can send
out formal letters with their name on
with where mail
merges
but I'll figure it
out can ask right now right right now I
just try to catch everything every day
and then uh but if I go away for three
or four days and it I come back with 400
emails in legislative mail and uh I just
uh edit them and cancel them all Chris
you can ask the legislative Tech Support
Office they're really helpful yeah I I
think I'm going to make a phone call
yeah I mean I know what folders are and
I use I have literally 80 folders in my
uh in the in my uh uh browser my Firs
that's on your desktop is your that's on
my desktop yeah so you have to drag it
from and then drop it in drag and
drop okay uh Anita don't forget to
follow follow up with that letter you
got you make millions oh I already did
I'm we're good we're we're going to
retire all right good we got it thank
you
Chris
um I probably have representative MC
Beth's phone number
right make sure she knows to get
on
see
she's still not on right has she been on
no I haven't seen her no I just checked
the
attendees
yeah we are still five minutes early
yeah I see that
so
[Music]
hi you uh we're we're ready for
you oh ouch
okay
um
I I'll I'm sure I'll will find someone
who will introduce it for
you no problem I'm glad I called so we
didn't we didn't wait for you so okay no
problem talk to you later
bye yes I'm in her phone too so uh she
is a Judiciary I guess is executive
right now so she's not going to be able
to do it so Christy she was asking if
you would be mine introducing or anybody
who like we've had for those the new
members we've had this pans somewhat
issue around um from the past but um
anybody anybody
feel well informed enough to want to
talk about
it don't all jump at once sure oh I'm
glad to do it okay great so we can wait
three minutes I guess and see if anybody
else
um
so you're a little bit early or you
gonna start um little early I guess we
can wait I don't know I can't believe I
don't care I'm here that department
should have only did 15 minutes for the
Department bill
but I
know know what I was thinking when I did
that and now I also
have um that Tyler will speak and then
Heidi will
speak and I see Heidi is here and I
assume Tyler Ty Tyler I never turned off
so
he's we ever let him leave when there
Insurance bills no no he's
not I don't know what we do without
Tyler all right all right well why don't
we just get going here so uh why don't
you do the best you can Christine okay
um uh for the record I'm representative
Christy Bartlett I represent maram
County District 19 which is located in
the city of conquered um I'm not on this
bill but I have worked on this issue for
the last couple of terms um pandas which
is the acronym for Pediatric AIO Auto
autoimmune neuros
psychiatric disorders sorry that's why
we call it pandas
um is a
very
complicated difficult to diagnose
condition and seems to affect
young
teenagers um right up through adulthood
and we had lots and lots of testimony by
various family members that have had to
deal with this um over a period of years
with their
children so this bill we we actually did
Implement a a bill I think it was two
years ago that provides some limited
coverage for the the pandas um
syndrome and this bill uh requires the
insurance commissioner to review the
implementation of the requirement
because and and report back to
legislature because there was a sunset
clause in there and now I don't remember
how many years it was for I think it was
for two years but it might have
been might have been three years do you
recall Connie or Joyce I think too yeah
I think so too so we're coming up um
onto that two-year limit and what we
want to know is whether the insurance
companies have been paying for uh well
to see what the what
the impact has been for covering um
treatment for this rare and very very
expensive
treatment is that enough it's perfect
okay so um so Tyler why don't you go
ahead and tell us what's been going on
in the department over this
issue sure so um Tyler Brandon with the
insurance department and thanks for that
that the nice comments uh happy to be
here as helpful as I can um so yes this
legislation passed a couple of years ago
it's a little unusual for an insurance
requirement though just want to say a
little about that it's um typically when
you get your health insurance it covers
a range of
services if an insurer decides Ed they
were not going to cover services for a
particular disease State say diabetes or
diabetics that would most likely be
considered discriminatory and it would
be
prohibited um this one actually does say
insurers will cover this particular
treatment condition but the reason for
that is because there's some
disagreement in the medical community
about the treatment and the condition so
it's sort of a legislative um step
forward or step backwards deping you're
looking at it in the way that it's
specifying coverage for particular
disease condition that typically would
be considered discriminatory if there
was a lot more clarity around the
disease condition um that being said New
Hampshire has access to our allpay
claims database or New Hampshire chis
which is a detailed but Anonymous set of
data that would normally allow the
insurance department to and identify at
least anonymously the number of people
who had a particular diagnosis a
particular condition and then the cost
and healthare services associated with
that
condition this one's a little bit uh
less straight forward because the
diagnosis code that would be used is
d89.89 and it's called it's described as
other specified disorders involving the
immune mechanism not elsewhere
classified so this diagnosis code might
be used for other conditions as well so
the department the way that we would go
to those claims dat be able to identify
the people and the treatment and
utilization so in order to satisfy the
requirements that are in this
legislation we'd actually have to
specify what we expect the carriers to
do in the way they're going to track the
patients and report to the department
there's not a lot of substance in the
legislation about what we would be
looking for um except perhaps the number
of patients and maybe something about
the cost and treatment but we would have
to tell the carriers to do this
prospectively I think most of them based
on the feedback I've gotten so far
haven't established kind of an effective
tracking mechanism because of this this
wishy-washiness with a diagnosis code
you might be able to look at um a couple
of other services that are likely to be
provided to these particular patients
but you're however you approach it
you're gonna end up I think with a lot
of false positives so kind of a wider
net than what you you really want um
ironically perhaps one of the ways the
carriers could identify these patients
is if there were some sort of prior
authorization for treatment but I won't
you know we've discussed prior
authoriz so um so I think maybe uh one
of the things that could be considered
if the legislation if there's interest
in passing the legislation is moving the
due date out from this November November
1st 2021 to something further in the
future so that we could tell the
carriers um when the legislation becomes
effective this is the kind of
information we're going to look for from
you um figure how to track it and we
could obviously have some back and forth
as to whether or not it's it's um going
to be an effective way to do it um but
uh but yeah that would be essentially
the only guidance or suggestion I think
I would provide um beyond what we could
do internally happy to take any
questions you have and uh thank you okay
anybody have any questions yes
representative
Herbert um I don't know if I understood
everything that was just said but did I
got the impression that uh Tyler the
insurance department uh probably
wouldn't mind looking into the matter
and getting some
clarity uh uh and then we can consider
legislation I don't I don't know I I
heard a cautionary tone to his remarks
in that there is this problem in regard
to diagnosis I think and uh uh we need
more information there
otherwise they're kind of don't know
what they've had what kind of data they
want to collect until cleared up so this
sounds to me like something we should
retain but uh or or you know uh yeah
retain or study whatever you want to use
and ask the insurance department to get
some clarity for
us uh is could be a would you believe or
you want to
resp yeah would you believe you don't
want to respond to that okay uh so
representative Fargo you have a question
but you're
muted
you're okay sorry I was just having a
little problem um thank you Mr
chairman Tyler do you remember from the
original bill when we passed it to allow
for coverage for this particular um
issue what the the date was that it
would expire because I have some
concerns that if we push out the date
for the reporting we may stop covering
this um and I I don't I I
remember us putting the bill through but
I don't remember when that coverage was
going to
stop was it
2025 I think it's
2024 could you check there for uh
representative MC Beth is is is on is is
here so we'll let her pick it up thank
you
Tyler so Bey you're on thank you I'm so
sorry hello to my colleagues and I I
really apologize for um being late we
had on Judiciary we had a unnoticed um
executive session so um I was in that um
but it was a friendly one there were no
objections um this bill this exact
language I believe passed
last year through the house Commerce
Committee um 20 to zero and it's a
followup to a bill that we had passed
the house both Chambers passed and the
governor actually signed it in July of
uh
2019 um so the bill in
2019 um required New Hampshire licensed
health insurance to cover the the pandis
collection of pandis illnesses
and um it sunsetted in five years so
that would be in
2024 I think 20 or 2023 John you you
remember this stuff better than me but
anyway this bill I'm sorry I can give
you the date if you want I just looked
it
up July 1 2024 2024 so because of the
fiveyear sunset this was um to collect
the data on the bill to to determine
whether or not you know citizens are
making claims whether they're being
covered you know whether or not this was
a beneficial bill um and or a beneficial
policy to cover that um in 2024 you know
we need to have the information from the
insurance um Department as to what
claims had been filed and and how it had
gone so it's really um it's just a
collection of data um from the health
insurance but again
we need to request the New Hampshire
Department of Health Insurance to
collect and analyze and report back to
us prior to that Sunset so I think that
the bill says that it would be reported
back you know in 2023 or something like
that but um I I I just heard a little
bit of Tyler's um I wasn't I mean the
the
bill had was not controversial and I if
something's different and it needs to be
changed I'd certainly leave that up to
to the committee thank
you
okay uh so we got some hands up now it's
um I see who who put their hand up first
okay representative
parlot sorry
Chris there we go okay
so sorry nothing go ahead oh um so Mr
Brandon so what you are I'm trying to
clarify here so you're saying that the
insurance companies haven't been able to
code this properly to be able to
determine at this point anyway determine
whether this treatment that the bill
covered is actually one being utilized
into two being effective is that correct
uh not quite so the diagnosis gets coded
by the health care provider and then
submitted on the claim and typically the
diagnosis used to justify the services
being provided the problem is the
diagnosis for this condition at least
the one that is coded when patients have
this condition is a bit of an all other
diagnosis code so it could be that
diagnosis code used could be used by a
health care provider for something else
so an company or the insurance
department using claims data would
identify potentially patients that are
not actually um diagnosed with pandis
the way uh it's described in the
legislation
so can I follow up for the question
thank you so if the in if the codes
aren't giving the insurance companies
enough specific
information with this bill what would
this bill do for us what would we gain
from this
bill well you would still require the
legislation would require the insurance
department to produce a report which
means we would make you know best effort
to work with the carriers to be able to
identify these patients and uh and be
able to report on them and it sounds
like based on your your testimony that
you're looking for really high level
information just the number of patients
whether or not um coverage was provided
so I think that's good news I think if
you want a lot of detail about the
services they receive and the costs then
it starts to get a little bit more
challenging but regardless the carriers
would have to develop a system for
tracking those patients which um was my
concern with the reporting due date if
we are planning to produce a report this
November that's not going to allow
enough time to effectively work with the
carriers to figure out how we're going
to track these patients and then produce
a report of value to
you further question thank you
so if the if the S sun sets July 1st of
2024 which is approximately three and a
half
years
how two and a half years how are we
gonna meet the requirements of the
bill and still be able to
provide the specialized treatment for
this rare
condition well the good news is we're
still only in 2021 so if you move the
reporting due date out of year so
November of 20122 you'd have it in time
before the session to make it effective
and continue the the
coverage okay so what we go back to um
representative MC Beth so you can think
you want to finish your thoughts
here thank you Mr chairman um one of the
reasons why the early reporting was
requested in the bill is because one of
the problems that we've seen across the
country and here in New Hampshire is
that there are different codes for the
treatment of this kind of myriad of of
of illnesses or chronic disease so um
having the uh New Hampshire Department
of Insurance kind of watching that and
then again they're not the education
piece but the pandis network or other
providers you know sharing information
well this is the code that you use for
this so it really is a you know in order
to figure out whether or not pandis is
being accessed you know for people's
insurance coverage um we need that kind
of incremental or stepped up you know
not a complete analysis every year but
some type of report back is like this is
how it's being coded for this provider
or this insurance company um I mean I
know that Paula Rogers testified last
year uh Anthem Blue Cross Blue Shield
they'd already been covering Panda so
this wasn't a new requirement for them
but one of the reasons they had a hard
time telling us how many cases they had
is because of the coding issue so um I
agree with Tyler that it is a you know
we're looking for kind of a high level
in the beginning and some information so
that then um you know the stakeholders
can figure out what they want to do with
that and then you know it'll it'll be
another report you know the following
year thank you thank you Mr chairman
thank representative
Herbert you'll get it one of these times
all right one of these days yeah um
thank you chairman hunt um so I was I
was under the Imp impression from
earlier remarks that this bill was going
to sunset in like a year and but that
was not the case and uh and so I was
that's when I got off into retention and
that kind of stuff but I don't
understand now that what I'm hearing I
don't understand why a bill is necessary
in order to have the
insurance uh Department uh do do that
research uh because the bill is is not
going to Sunset for over two years or
three years maybe so it's always going
to be an effect why are we passing
legislation to get a study done I don't
I don't quite understand that you want
to answer that
Rebecca
Becky I'll defer to you Mr chairman
thank you well that's good I mean well
because we well I mean I would assume
that we have limited resources in our
department of insurance and they are not
they're not constantly auditing every um
coded condition I I mean and so why
would they be reporting back to us I
mean we need the information reported
back at a certain time I mean I I I
don't know that we have you know they do
that we can ask Tyler but I I don't
think we'll get this information unless
we ask for it and certainly we won't get
it so that we can try to help people be
covered in this period of two and a half
years before it
sunsets do you want to take take tackle
that Tyler sure yeah no it's um I I I
think it's a good question because we do
produce analyses that uh are hopefully
insightful about the facts that are
related to legislation and we do that
within existing resources this is a bit
different because we'd have to create a
new reporting requirement for the
carriers and I think for us to do that
it would be very helpful to have uh
clear legislative direction that it's
important or it's felt important by the
legislature for the insurance department
to expend resources well both at the
department and at the carriers to
produce the
information
yeah I I guess um I'm trying to drag my
memory
um because I feel like we this where we
had to build twice and the first time we
didn't do anything second time we came
back and we had the department to try to
tell us what there's a problem tell us
what's out there how do we track it
because it was clear that different
insurance companies were treating it in
a different fashion and terms of the
diagnosis codes but just each one had
their own way of looking at it and my
memory the original bill was to mandate
some medication that that was that and
that was controversial to begin with so
then um so I guess that the my best
guess the reason why we did what we did
was for you the department to come back
and say well here's what we know know
about whatever world of pandas that
exists and whether there's coverages or
whether there's issues that still can be
up there but but here's what we know so
far is that Poss
I don't recall that specific Dialogue on
it but it may have taken place with
somebody else from the Department okay
all right uh representative MC Beth and
then on representative
Barlett so thank you for jogging my
memory too yes the original bill which
did one of there was an issue about the
plasma there was expensive plasma
exchange so it's a Tre a treatment um
and um what was happening is that the
original bill this passed and that
Governor sonunu signed on his desk he
supported it um um it required that
insurance carriers Health in New
Hampshire that they offer that that that
be one of the tools that they allow
providers to have I think that was one
of the controversies that not that
hadn't been authorized as a by all
insurance carriers as a treatment for
this
pandis condition and so I think that was
one of the reasons we wanted this track
is how many how many pro medical
providers are uh recommending that for
their you know their their patients and
how many people are actually getting it
covered I think that was part of it um
so that we could and then the code issue
there were there were several confusing
things about it but thank you great
representative
bartand uh oh she froze it certainly was
could few years of very passionate um
testimony from the families but I I
think that um representative McBeth has
got this right is that some of the
carriers were willing to do a less
expensive treatment but they weren't
willing to do the really expensive
treatment and that caused the
controversy but the compromise on the
bill that passed was that we would have
a review of whether this
expensive treatment was effective over
time so my question to Tyler is if we
put this out to say um November of
2022 is that more doable do you
think yeah that's what I was initially
thinking although um the level of detail
that you may actually be interested in
would make the reporting requirement I
think a little more complex assuming you
are looking for for whether or not I
guess the more expensive treatment is
being provided that that level of detail
um you don't think that would show
insurance carriers because it is it's
got to be a a huge line item when I mean
we were talking 750,000 to a million
dollars at the time that's gonna show up
in in somebody's
report even if it's miscellanous
sure I don't know I thought it was just
a handful of cases yeah it was just a
handful of cases but it was so expensive
and the alternative was in one family
the child landed on up in jail because
of the various kinds of yeah
symptoms uh well okay um so I do have I
do have Heidi Heidi croll so uh Heidi
you out there so I can yeah all right
let
it's Heidi you're GNA get the last word
here
Heidi
there she is all right hope you enjoyed
your time at Health and Human Services
and H yes I was over in Senate energy
energy okay I'm back um happy to be with
you um for the record um my name is
Heidi craw I work at Gallagher cahan in
gartell and I represent um ahip which is
America's health insurance plans um the
trade Association for the health
insurance carriers um so I've been
following the discussion here and so
here's what I understand the challenge
to be and I'll I'll try to um be clear
about this uh happy to try to answer
questions but from what I understand
there is not a specific diagnosis code
for pandis so there is a lack of an
icd10 code or specific diagnosis from
the American Academy of
Pediatrics um so
that's part of the challenge is that we
um we don't have a diagnosis code where
we can clearly
identify um who the pandis patients are
um we know from the past um uh work on
this bill that there were um a variety
of treatments um I think uh OCD if I
remember correctly kind of OCD symptoms
were part of um this
um uh disease I guess we'd call it and
so you know that that was part of
treatment sometimes I think the
expensive treatment that was being
referred to was the
IVIG um the problem with that is that um
the use of IVIG is uh used in other for
other patients as well um it's used for
different um uh rheumatoid diseases
rtic diseases so um again there's if you
depending on how you cast this net you
are going to be capturing people who are
not pandas patients so
um you know we appreciate the
opportunity potentially to get the date
pushed out but I'm not sure that that's
going to help us solve problem since
it's it's not really
the the carriers aren't really um
standing in the way of identifying who
these people are it's the lack of
diagnosis codes um and the lack of a
very specific treatment that's received
um received only by these by these
patients um the other thing I guess I'd
mention is um you know I'm wondering if
there potentially is another way to get
at this um obviously we have the the
mandate the coverage mandate um like all
coverage mandates uh presumbly the
carriers are covering that and I'm
wondering if there's um have been any
complaints um consumer complaints
registered with the New Hampshire
insurance department
um over lack of coverage or concern
because I think we did hear in Prior
years testimony on this that um but the
people had reached out to the insurance
department and so you you know that
would be at least one place to look um
to see if they've received any
complaints since the passage of of the
bill um so I I don't really have a good
answer for the solution here um I I'm
only here to share the problem with you
um which is just the the kind of
challenges that this bill poses in terms
of trying to track folks um to get you
the information that you're interested
in
okay any questions of Heidi yes Joyce
excuse me representative Weston yes uh
thank you heidy for your testimony um
how does one get an icd10
code I don't know I can try to find out
for you but um I'm not sure but that's
what I was told that there's a lack of
an icd10 code or a specific diagnosis
from the American Academy of
Pediatrics um which makes tracking
pandis difficult if not impossible
exactly okay seems it needs to be
rectified there well it because there
was there's so it it it because it has
so many different elements to it in
terms of the symptoms that that it get
usually gets whatever it's being
addressed is usually being dressed for
that other those other symptoms rather
than defining it as pens right as Tyler
mentioned there's a non-specific code um
called a disorder involving the immune
mechanism
unspecified right um but of course there
are other people who don't have pandas
who are also coded that
way right right exactly because it's a
catch on exactly right uh let's see I
have a couple hands up now uh so
representative
Abramson thank thank you Mr chair and
thank you for taking my question um I do
have a uh question do you know what the
cost of
the um
sorry intravenous immune globulin
treatment is is it going to vary from
Patient to Patient how often I I would
have to get back to you um I'm happy to
look into that and get back to you I
don't want to um speak out of hand um I
do um as representative Bartlett
mentioned I do recall that some of these
treatments were were pretty expensive
but I'm not sure that that's always the
case for every patient so I can um I can
look into that and get back to
you so there's not a real protocol in
terms of the step system on how to deal
with this because um it it really is uh
symptom driven you know what are the
symptoms that the person's having and
that's what they're end up trying to
trying to uh cure but uh representative
Fargo um yes can everybody hear me this
time yes we can thank you Mr chairman um
is there a potential to perhaps see if
there was an uptick in that particular
Uniden U kind of uh blanket code after
we passed the legislation that would
indicate that there was um an abundance
of pandas cases that would be affecting
it because I think the original reason
we wanted this reporting was to
determine whether we wanted to continue
to provide the coverage
and so just I'm wondering Tyler if you
could see whether there was any kind of
um a change after we put that
legislation through that would indicate
some factor for
us uh short answer is yes I mean to
extent you're just looking for a rate uh
build by that diagnosis code so you
could um yeah and we could do that with
existing resources I think so the
existing claims database the department
has access to and uh um and Consulting
resources so uh representative MC Beth
um what I'm thinking now is is that
maybe maybe retaining this bill is the
right idea but we would want from the
insurance department Tyler is uh that by
come come next Fall you guys can give us
a preliminary report or give tell us
where you guys are at with it what do
you know what do we've learned you know
just give us some tidbits so that you
know we can then come September October
when we take it review the bill again we
can at least see where where we're at
right at that time is that possible yes
definitely okay you you okay with that
megy move yes thank you thank you Mr
chairman I would be okay with that thank
you very much thank you Tyler all right
I think that might be the right solution
for now all right uh and I have no one
else who wants to speak on this bill um
I have oh Shane B oh yes Shane yes go
ahead Jane
sorry all right um this is my first you
know um year on this committee I really
haven't heard you know much about you
know many of these uh issues but it
sounds like it's a pretty
invasive uh procedure if it's that
costly it um because it sounds like
maybe there are many doctors that don't
approve of this treatment or am I could
somebody sort of explain why it's so
expensive uh well again it's that was
the medication that that was being that
was all right was very expensive but U
but again that medication was more of
the symptom that particular symptom that
it was manifesting itself rather than
that you know you you're you're
diagnosed to having pens and and this is
what we're going to give you all right
so so it's it's it's a conundrum did I
get that right Christie yeah
thanks right I think what um you know
somebody coming into this cold doesn't
have a clue what the symptom was and
it's a it's somebody what they have
found out is that it's um from children
that have had strep throat and it has
some kind it's a neurological disease it
affects the brain but it comes out in
many different ways um and the
treatments are are complicated and this
particular treatment um is very
expensive but it has shown according to
many of those those that testified that
were able to afford it that there was
some efficacy on it so that's why we
worked so hard to get it one I mean one
lady lost her house because she spent
all of her money for treatment um
another one had the money it was a
doctor's uh child and it goes on for
years I mean it take it took I think in
one case it took six or seven years to
even diagnose it yeah but many different
manifestations of the disease and it's
really Insidious so doctors are grasping
all right so represent MC Beth I'll let
you have the the last word here so I
just wanted to agree with everything
that was said the immunog globan
treatment what it's it's very similar to
the treatment they give you if you are
being treated for rabies and they have
to take plasma from healthy people and
they mix it with you know whatever
they're doing to fight the rabies and so
um it is a patient specific it's based
on weight and and how much you know what
your exposure is um but so it's not
really that strange of a treatment it's
just it's expensive I think that a
rabies shot you know regimen can be
about $10,000 if you do not have
insurance so but that's what this
immunoglobin is it's taking stuff you
know blood product out of somebody else
and it's injecting it into you know I
mean that is such a scientific
explanation but I just wanted you to
understand it's not that weird of a
concept it's something that we all might
you know know somebody that's had that
type of
treatment fair enough okay so I have H
Jennifer Jones uh who's a member of the
public who's in support of the bill uh
Eric wrathman and is also a member of
the public and supports the bill
and um and I have then Sabrina Dunlap
from the from uh Anthem which is neutral
on this legislation and with that we'll
close the public hearing on House Bill
201 and it's 218 so we're gonna go right
into another old
favorite it's nice seeing you Becky take
care all right uh representative Weston
you know are you ready
to I to revisit this one and this is an
old favorite you're absolutely right
been going on for about 10 years now I I
I think I think I remember this going
back when I first got on the committee
this issue it's it's always it's always
been around but well you you're the one
who would know that right so chairman
hunt Commerce Committee thank you for
the opportunity to introduce this bill
uh for the record my name is Joyce
Weston I represent Grafton 8 which is a
towns of Hein holderness and
Plymouth uh this deal deals with the
problem of surprise billing uh a balance
bill after an ambulance ride and a study
from brigam Bram and Women's Hospital in
Boston found that 71% of ambulance rods
are likely to generate a surprise bill
with an average cost to the patient of
$450 uh ambulances have the highest out
of network billing rate of any medical
specialty and when you're in need of an
amb ambulance you don't necessarily have
the capacity to choose whether the
ambulance is in or out of your network
and you probably have no choice as to
whether to accept the ride at all but
you could be hit with a substantial bill
which creates additional hard hardship
both financially and emotionally on top
of the injury or
illness this bill bans this
practice uh in New Hampshire local
governments supported by our property
taxes provide the majority of ambulance
rides um via the fire departments or
Standalone rescue
squads the cost is a huge burden to our
small towns um I live in one of them and
our um and our property tax rate hovers
around just under $30 on a
thousand uh it's a
cost um uh this is because the
reimbursement rates offered by in
contract negotiations with insurance
providers are woefully
inadequate this bill requires the
insurance carriers to offer a
commercially reasonable payment and I'm
sure we'll he hear from Tyler brenon
about that
wording um if there's a dispute the um
commissioner of the New Hampshire
insurance department will determine if
the fee is
appropriate one thing we added to this
bill though is that they have to
consider the higher costs in rural
communities um reimbursement payments
aside there's a ma National move against
balance billing in December uh 2020
Congress passed legislation to ban I
have to turn off my phone excuse me to
ban surprise um all surprise medical
bills with one notable exception and
that's ground ambulances in response to
this Omission several states are trying
to fill the Gap through
legislation uh Maryland and Colorado
have added ambulances to their surprise
billing ban the Department of Insurance
in Texas has recommended it New York and
Illinois have similar bills to the one
that we have here and Colorado insurers
are now required to pay ambulances
325 per of the Medicare rate
Medicare uh does ban balance billing but
it has absurdly low reimbursement rates
in uh Plymouth it's around
13.2% of the
cost um they are they do have a program
going on right now though which is
reviewing its payment rates um under
pressure from
Congress um but this process is going to
take
years um I heard from one fire that it's
going to be about five years before we
actually get any
change in the process of of working on
this bill I talked to a lot of
interested parties and I'm re very much
aware that the ambulance services are
underfunded and they're worried about a
loss of Revenue I'm sure we'll hear
testimony on that
today but I also think it's important
for you to know that this year because
of the difficulty of our session we want
wanted to keep this a simple Bill we
didn't try to resolve all the problems
of how to get
reasonably um uh reasonable reinsured in
insurance
reimbursement so we T decided to really
focus on balance billing and then I
would like to work with some of the
people I've been talking with to come up
with a more comprehensive Bill to deal
with the other issues in
2022 so uh for now um this is about
balance billing and uh I'm happy to take
some
questions any questions from the
committee okay seeing none um chair
we'll call on Tyler Tyler Brennan and
Tyler so why don't you give us the
Department's
perspective so Tyler Brandon from the
New Hampshire insurance department and
we don't have a position on the bill but
we would be very supportive of a
legislative solution to ambulance
balance billing this is seen by the
department as a one of our bigger
consumer concerns we do receive
complaints from consumers who have been
balance build by out of network
ambulance companies and uh it's a very
difficult sort of challenge to solve
so luck we'd be very supportive of a
legislative solution um the earlier
legislation that passed in 2018 dealing
with balance billing was specific to
four different hospital-based
professional providers anesthesiologists
Radiologists Pathologists and emergency
medicine physicians and the concept
wasse if a patient or a member chose an
in network Hospital made sure the
surgeon was in network went there and
received care from an add a network
anesthesiologist um that would be a
surprise bill but the patient did
everything they were supposed to so one
of the overriding goals with that
legislation was to keep the patient out
of any dispute they should be protected
in these
circumstances the model proposed in uh
in this legislation is actually very
similar so um restrictions on what
ambulance companies can bill and
similarly an expectation that carriers
pay a commercially reasonable amount one
of the other goals with that earlier
legislation and I will say that
legislation followed a study committee
that was chaired by Neil Kirk and in my
experience at the department which is
now close to 15 years I've never seen a
study committee work so hard at hearing
from all the different interested
parties and trying to come up with a
solution that really balanced interest
as as best as possible I I don't think
the legislation would have passed
without that time investment and hearing
everybody and really crafting a solution
that um met the other goal which was to
avoid any kind of rate setting by the
state and rate setting can happen
explicitly you could say they're going
to pay 325 of Medicare like it sounds
like Chicago has done or it could happen
because there's a default that one party
is better off under so in other words if
uh there's no agreement met between the
parties it defaults to Medicare plus 325
per or something like that then each
part is going to look at where they
stand today whether not they're better
off under the default and you're going
to end up with a default fee schedule in
those circumstances so one of the goals
that representative Kirk had was let's
put language in there around
commercially reasonable let's make use
of the insurance Department's access to
the claims data to see what other
providers are paid but let's not tell
the carrier or the provider uh enough
that a decision about what's
commercially reasonable can be e can be
made easily so in other words they've
got a petition in the department it's a
public hearing that basically have to
come in and say this was my final offer
and the other party wouldn't accept it
so generally a pretty uncomfortable
process and um the success of of that
earlier legislation has been has been
very high we haven't received any
petitions from providers or from
carriers and the number of balance
billing complaints the department has
received um in this context and in
network Hospital provider is very low
these days so I think it's been a
success on a number of fronts but one of
the big differences between ambulance
companies and those hospital-based
providers is at the time that legisl
ation passed most of those providers
were in network so you didn't want to
create kind of a new Dynamic with the
legislation that would encourage either
party not to contract the way they had
in the past my understanding of today's
environment is that many of these
ambulance companies are out of network
so the likelihood that they would be
petitioning the department to resolve a
disagreement would be much higher so the
department may have to play a much more
significant role in in in resolving some
of these disputes
perfect Jeffrey represent gson you have
a question
for actually sorry uh thank you actually
my question may be for you since you
have a a lot more experience as you's
mentioned that this bill has been around
for eternity uh how has how is this bill
compared to previous versions of the
bill does this bill plug holes that
other bills OB from other bills uh just
I guess what makes this bill different
from what's happened in the past that we
would pass at this time and when it
didn't pass in the past yeah well I mean
basically um you know that as as Tyler
mentioned there was another study
committee dealing with a balance billing
issue and uh that got a resolution so
they took that language and lifted it
and tried to apply it to the ambulance
and as Tyler mentioned what the one
downside the problem is is that uh most
of these ambulance companies do not have
are not in the network with the
hospitals with the do with Excuse me
with the insurance companies so by
because they don't have those contracts
um and and and we I do have Chris St was
here he he will help you understand the
the um ambulance company's point of view
and if I may follow up Sir with you
there a reason why these ambulances are
no longer in network or they never work
that was that's the thing they never
were
okay so okay put your hand down that'd
be great so now I'll call on Chris day
was to
uh offer up his opposition to this
bill good afternoon can you hear me yep
okay I'm just trying to get my video
going here sorry there I
am um well thank you for the opportunity
to speak to you today about House Bill
343 uh my name is Chris dwaz I'm a
lifelong New Hampshire resident and
reside uh in the town of Hollis with my
wife and family I've been a nationally
registered paramedic for the last 35
years and spent my entire Adult Career
in the New Hampshire Emergency Medical
Services industry I'm currently employed
by American Medical Response AMR which
is the nation's largest ground and air
Medical Transportation provider and I am
currently the regional director for AMR
in New Hampshire and Maine as well as
their a Northeast Regional director of
government affairs
AMR is the largest provider of 911
emergency medical services in our state
we are the exclusive 911 provider for
the the clerk can't the clerk is having
trouble hearing yeah so Chris your your
audio is really okay oh that was better
what did you just do you my head is that
better yeah okay it's much better now
thank you okay all right if it goes
again just feel free to to let me know I
you have one of those here here in yeah
again go ahead uh AMR is the largest 911
provider in the state of New Hampshire
and the ambulance provider for yeah
don't don't Bob your head I'm gonna
switch off this thing hold on one second
here let me that might be a better idea
let me go to my other method I apologize
for
that no can't hear you at
all chairman uh hunt yes the qu the
question is why are they not in in
service or what in house he's going to
give us his testimony what we'll get
we'll get we'll get his testimony okay
yeah I just want to make sure what the
question he has to answer he's actually
testifying this is not he's not being
posed a question at this point okay he's
testifying why he's in opposition to
this
bill okay
okay I think I'm back there you go that
works okay thank you sorry about that
folks uh we employ over 200 licensed New
Hampshire EMS providers operating from
multiple locations throughout the
granite state and transport over 40,000
patients annually we share the
legislative goal of providing our
customers with the necessary information
to make informed decisions about their
healthc care choices we believe that New
Hampshire house bill 343 is no longer
required or in the public interest due
to the recent Passage of the federal
surprise medical billing act all EMS
providers have a legal duty to respond
to emergency service request regardless
of the patient's ability to pay that
Duty applies to Municipal providers like
fire departments commercial providers
like us as well as volunteer and
hospital-based EMS providers New
Hampshire EMS providers generally
receive payment only when a patient is
transported to a hospital we are not
reimbursed for our 27 our 247 readiness
our response or even for the care
provided to patients at a scene unless
we also transport that patient to a
hospital nearly one-third of emergency
ambulance service responses do not
result in a patient transport meaning
EMS currently has no ability to pay for
those services but still Bears the cost
to provide the service
247 interestingly enough there's
actually a uh piece of legislation in
the federal government right now as we
speak was which believe was just
introduced produced
yesterday which would be a temporary Gap
to that inability to receive service
payment for treatment without transport
I believe it was a Senate bill that was
just introduced um literally
yesterday but passage of this bill here
in New Hampshire as written would
essentially force all New Hampshire EMS
providers to immediately become in
network with all commercial insurance
carriers without what we believe any
factual justification of what a
commercially reasonable value for the
services they individually provide is
this would have an immediate and likely
devastating impact on numerous Municipal
budgets across the state as the badly
needed Revenue that so many New
Hampshire cities and towns depend upon
to fund their local EMS systems would
suddenly drop the centers for Medicare
and Medicaid services CMS recently
instituted a national mandatory cost
study for all ground EMS providers
beginning this year with 20% of all the
ambulance service providers years
enrolled annually in the study for each
year next five years we would suggest
that in the absence of meaningful cost
data that is impossible to determine
what a commercially reasonable value for
service truly is given the complex
nature of New Hampshire's EMS provider
demographics the cost of 247 Readiness
for an ambulance provider in Berlin for
instance varies significantly what the
cost of Readiness would be for an
ambulance service in conquer or
Portsmith or Kean while House Bill 343
makes excellent attempts to find
Solutions and I think we all agree that
patients should be held harmless
whenever possible the United States
Congress recently passed and the
president signed Federal surprise
medical billing act that we believe
potentially usurps New Hampshire house
bill
343 the new federal SMB Law requires
among other things the creation of a
National Ground EMS Advisory Group that
group is charged with determining the
safest and fairest possible path for
Equitable payments to ground Ambulance
Service Services
Nationwide the advisory committee is
required to report solutions back to
Congress within the next six months we
believe that it would be better for
patients if the state of New Hampshire
did not place duplicative or burdensome
regulations on its EMS providers these
additional State compliance costs will
inevitably have to be passed on to
citizens of New Hampshire and May in the
end conflict with the newly passed
Federal SMB law even more pressing is
yet another National Emergency
stretching EMS to its limits especially
in the state of New Hampshire which
continues to struggle with an ongoing
opioid epidemic as well as a worldwide
pandemic ambulance services are a
critical part of the front line of
defense for the covid-19 pandemic as a
profession our expenses have climbed
significantly due to increased PPE
requirements paying employees through
required quarantine time as well as
their own illness times our revenues
have dropped dramatically due to lower
call transport volume as people restrict
restrict their movements And Delay
seeking care adding additional State
Legislative requirements now potentially
puts the continued viability of many EMS
providers throughout the state at risk
during a time when we can least afford
to do so so we respectfully ask that in
the public interest you find this bill
inexpedient to legislate and allow the
new federal SMB law to address the issue
I thank you for your time and I'm more
than happy to answer any questions that
any members of the committee may have
great because we do have a couple uh
representative AB you're first thank you
Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question um do you have uh services that
go across uh state lines transporting we
have a lot of people live in seab Brook
and uh a lot of people get transported
down to Anna Jake in
Massachusetts that uh service area I
believe in in those cases would be the
Seabrook fire department that would
handle those but I mean does does your
do your uh uh paramedics transport
people across state lines for transports
oh oh yes yes they do um and followup F
the question me inquire uh would this
bill uh do you think have a have an
impact uh in cases like that would that
would that create additional problems
for
them it's difficult to say I think it
would add an additional layer of um uh
something that each individual ambulance
service provider would have to be able
to examine in our case for instance at
AMR we're we're in network with a number
of different
uh insurance carriers Anthem being
obviously the largest so from that
standpoint it wouldn't impact us but I
know that many of the 911 providers in
the state are not in network with
anybody um simply due to the fact that
the amount that the insurance carriers
are willing to pay nowhere near meets
the cost that the 911 providers incur uh
and and to be forced into those um
situations like that literally overnight
uh as I said would have an incredible
effect on a lot of fire department
budgets and Municipal budgets across the
state all right thank you uh
representative
burrow yes thank you for uh taking my
question um I guess Chris what confuses
me maybe you can help me is that they're
not a lot of businesses that that I know
of um that don't get paid for so much of
their
services um you know you said you don't
get paid unless you transport some
somebody so is have you as have EMTs
either in in state or across the country
have they looked at the business model
and are there any ways that you can get
compensated um either by you again this
is all new to me so through the towns or
or other means because it just seems
like a um an unworkable system yeah well
it's not unlike an emergency room for
instance um many of the folks that go to
emergency rooms are either underinsured
not insured and you know most of us that
are that are um have the luxury of being
able to be on this call today probably
have pretty good commercial insurance
I'm guessing or we have a federal
governmental product that in essence um
in our system of Health Care in the
United States today pays for those
people who cannot afford for that care
the ambulance service world is no
different um in fact well I I shouldn't
say that it is different because we
don't have the luxury of obtaining a uh
insurance card while you're on the side
of the road or or having you know your
your heart attack in your home we just
provide the Serv and take you and look
for the information later on so we're at
somewhat of a disadvantage that many
other medical providers are not at um
yet we still have to provide that level
of care followup really question yes
thank you um well with an and and a
disclosure my husband was an emergency
um medical um physician for 30 years and
in the hospital with with emergency
departments so they get bailed out by
the hospital by higher Revenue
generating um services like you know
Orthopedics and whatnot so do do these
EMT groups ever align with hospitals so
there could be a similar scenario where
they could Finance the the the parts
that that that aren't
paid I think in years past in in my
history of work I previously worked for
a company called Rockingham ambulance
which was part of St Joseph's healthcare
in Nash for many many years uh St Joseph
divested from Rockingham because of all
of the other costs that they were
burdened with as a healthcare
organization they were no longer able to
support the ambulance company and
literally walked away from it um thank
you thank you for for answering that
right well but I think the answer to
your question is is that's they do cost
shift and they get to when they do
actually carry a patient that they're
going to be Bild in that bill whatever
that bill is is going to be higher
because of their underlying costs that
they have you know they got to get their
money somehow so it's just that's where
the cost shifting is all right uh
representative V
hooton thank you Mr chair and thank you
Chris for being here to testify I note
that just about every reference to the
word ambulance is preceded by the word
ground is there a difference um both in
how it is done locally and in the
Congressional Bill to which you
alluded I I referenced the ground
because the other side of that is the
air component and air is federally
mandated because of the lures that are
involved so states can cannot um have
any regulations that they can impose on
the air ambulance industry that all has
to to come through Congress so we
specifically reference that it's ground
ambulance and not
air yep so the Congressional bill that
you referenced would cover both ground
and air ambulance service am I
correct it it does there's actually a
piece in the bill that specifically
talks to the air side of things um and
then one that specifically talks to the
ground side which is the Congressional
committee that's been that's being put
together thank you good to see you right
so so you're saying they haven't really
solved the ground problem they just set
up a study committee to solve the ground
problem they have because the difficulty
quite frankly as I mentioned earlier is
we don't know what the ual cost uh of of
Readiness and what a fair compensation
cost is and CMS has been tasked with
determining what that is and until
they've complete that cost study you're
really taking a dart and throwing it at
a board um and as I mentioned you know
what um there's an ambulance service in
our Northern uh most Community called
the 45th parallel what their costs are
up there are certainly not what our
costs are in natural um there's a Lar
larger territory to cover there's
there's a tremendous amount of
difference in the demographics and
without a meaningful cost study of what
a fair and Equitable payment rate would
be as I said it's it's a it's a
crapshoot um and it's you know speaking
from what I do I don't want to take a
crapshoot with my budget it's too
important to the communities that we
serve and the level of services that we
provide and I don't think many other
ambulance providers want to do that
either now each community by the way can
also
instill its own Cost Containment
controls for instance um in nsha and
Manchester written into our contracts
with those communities are caps on the
amount of out-of-pocket billing that we
can Bill our customers uh we're we're
only allowed to out-of-pocket Bild
Medicare plus 25% to anybody that we
pick up under those contractual
agreements in those communities and and
that was those communities attempt to um
provide price protection to their
constituents now their volume allows
them to be able to do that you know that
certainly wouldn't be the same situation
in some of the smaller communities but
in those it works for them and they came
up with a local
solution so then if there's a c do you
back build the city does pay any money
no the city No in fact in those two
communities we pay the city money for
the services they provide to us um and
dispatching fees so we actually pay the
cities of Nashville and Manchester
several hundred, a year to have them
dispatch our ambulance as for us well
this is a complicated one okay it is
yeah right so Connie are you all set
then yeah your head take your hand down
okay uh Rich representative Abel did you
have another
question yes thank you um in the uh
cities where or the uh areas where your
company uh
operates um do ambulance certain
ambulance companies have an exclusive uh
rangement in other words ises a City
License them uh or the town uh or is
there
competition uh so they could call you
they could call someone
else most communities where we operate
we're under an agreement with those
communities and the agreement specifies
a number of different things from types
of personnel their training levels their
response time uh requirements um what
our pricing structure is uh for instance
we're required to be nationally
accredited uh in both those communities
so there's a whole list of things that
that each Community um would require of
of the uh ambulance provider before they
would sign an agreement with them I
don't know of very many communities
where it's uh you know you you call and
and you can choose from a list of of of
folks uh there's standards that are out
there that that most communities abide
by
thank great uh seeing nobody else so
thank you very much for your testimony
thank you for the opportunity yeah so uh
last but not least uh least natch natch
Grace from the municipal Association
and good afternoon Mr
chair good afternoon Mr chair and
members of the committee um so I'm an
attorney with the New Hampshire
Municipal
Association I just want to comment on
the bill um because there are some
things that we think are good and some
things we are concerned about uh that
our members have reached out to us on so
beginning with the things that are good
uh our communities have pretty much
universally said and I think that those
of you who've been on this committee and
heard similar bills through the year
have uh have already heard them say that
providing payments directly to the
ambulance provider rather than to the
person transported and then expecting
that person who's transported to then
pass that money on to the provider is a
good change um because there are
instances many instances where uh
persons are reimbursed by the insurance
provider uh and then they do not
actually pay the ambulance service um
obviously you know they're having a
medical issue so a lot of those costs
end up going to other other medical
bills
um but in terms of our concerns um the
the concerns really center around the uh
commercially reasonable language um and
how exactly that's going to work
out uh you know our our communities
obviously don't own hospitals they don't
operate uh emergency rooms um so they're
not familiar with that
experience uh and the concern is
obviously that if you know uh a
community runs a Ambulance Service um
and then has disputes with insurance
providers that they're constantly
running
to the insurance commissioner um and
asking for Resolutions um for these for
these fees and they're really in this
kind of middle place where they're
trying to figure where they're trying to
mediate um what happens and what the
costs are going to be that are going to
be associated with that um so those are
some of the concerns that we've that
we've heard
uh and I just want to share that with
the committee and I'm happy to take any
questions yeah great great for uh thank
you for pointing out uh section seven
and eight I was so busy looking at the
the other ambulance issue I forgot all
about
that yet another ambulance issue that we
have which is that uh if someone's
property in casual auto insurance that
if they're using the med pay the money
gets paid directly to the patient to the
car the know the policy owner and not to
the provider which uh we heard uh I
guess one example I heard was that some
people they actually had a $115,000 med
pay and they took the check and went out
and bought a boat
trailer instead of paying the medical
providers they to pill it and do
services so uh any other questions from
the committee for for
NCH uh seeing then we thank you very
much thank you very much and I oh we do
have some hand up all of a sudden we got
some other hands up oh God Don all right
Don funin wants to weigh
in and hey Don who are we representing
today this afternoon oh let's
see we um I'm I'm I'm here again um uh
for
ahip um
we we are pleased to uh support
representative Weston's bill um as it
relates to the prohibition on balance uh
billing um unlike the last speaker
though um we believe Mr Brennan's
explanation is
is persuasive and it and that is uh we
support
parties uh being commercially reasonable
as it relates to payment and their other
U uh conduct uh so we we support that
provision and the
related um mechanism in the event of a
dispute as well the only issue we have
really with the bill is section
seven and if that's one of the uh
Provisions that representative Weston
referred to earlier um as something that
she was interested in working on um we
certainly would be uh party to that U
effort the
reason we are concerned with it is the
provision which is being requested that
you
delete um is one actually similar to the
commercial reasonableness standard
tends to encourage reasonable Behavior
as opposed
to less than that and and and the reason
for that quite frankly is those of you
that have ever dealt with a two-party
check uh uh
know um that uh if if people want to
cash check they pretty much have to uh
uh come to a mutual
uh uh understanding in order to do that
that's what's in the current law um we
think that makes sense and for that
reason we are pleased to support
representative Weston's uh bill with the
exception of section seven and uh I
still have the boat uh Mr chairman
and okay good to
hear any questions uh for
attorney funin seeing none we thank you
all right uh next is I have
Justin uh R
romanello so Justin where where do you
fall on this issue so my name is Justin
romanello I appreciate your time I'm the
chief of the Bureau of Ems for the State
of New Hampshire um and I just kind of
wanted to uh kind of bring some
clarifying points as to what New
Hampshire EMS system looks like as far
as Services um if I could so in the
state we have 300 licensed EMS units and
about half of those are transport and
services where this was this bill would
apply to so they're the one you know
they have an ambulance and they
transport patients to the scene and into
the hospital um or inner facility so
between medical facility and medical
facility um of those
those 167 is departments 2third are
municipal Based Services so they are
majority being fire uh services but they
are municipal Based Services with about
45ish um are either hospital-based or um
like Chris said Chris was they're a
private Ambulance Service and again
they're providing service 911 services
as well as inter facility transport um
so I just wanted to paint that picture I
know there is some conversations as far
as talking about ground ambulances um
and talking about commercial ambulances
um but it is it is a bit of a larger
picture with that there are municipal
Based Services there is only one service
that I am aware of that does not build
their residents uh in the state it is a
municipal Service uh and they don't bill
for any transports what whatsoever um
but the majority of those departments
that 167 transport Serv departments are
in fact going to bill for their services
and to a point that that Chris made as
far as not billing for anything other
than transports you know it does it does
certainly raise the the issue that over
half of our services that are licens in
the state are providing uh life life uh
saving functions uh that that never
never build for that matter um but
certain we can answer any questions I
just wanted to kind of paint the
landscape of of what units are out there
in the state
are you for or against this bill I am I
am
neutral okay okay do we have any
questions from the committee members
seeing none thank you very much thank
you all right next we have Chuck
hean and you have to unmute yourself
check
[Music]
hello can you hear me there we go great
yes we can hear on that side say could
be easily
T well thank you ladies and gentlemen
and thank you for the opportunity for me
to uh speak in opposition to House Bill
343 um I do agree in lockstep with Chris
dewas I've known Chris for many years
he's a well-known very well-respected
EMS administrator in the state of New
Hampshire and again I agree with him
completely so what I wanted to mention
to you and make you aware of is I'm the
EMS director for the dairy fire
department I have been a paramedic for
36 years and I've devoted my entire life
to public service and as a EMS director
I'm resp responsible for the billing
aspect of our operation so I'm often
asked by residents and why do they get a
bill for ambulance transport when they
pay taxes why doesn't the taxes cover
that bill and my response is typically
in Derry only 5% of of our residents
actually use our service but 95% do not
95% of people which is a good thing do
not have a medical emergency that
requires a call to 911 in our
response so we look at it or I kind of
look at it more as a user fee to pay for
that service whether we go to the town
tax base and ask for 100% to cover our
operations or we build for our EMS
Service uh is kind of a user fee because
only 5% of the people use it so when I
look at our payer mix and I wanted to
kind of explain that to you and see just
so you have an understanding of what
we're up against here in EMS our current
payer mix and dairy and these are all
the payers 50% of our residents have
Medicare but when you have Medicare we
receive 80% of the fee scheduled the
patient's responsible for
20% so I agree with that completely and
I I think we those that have Medicare I
have no issue with collecting the 80%
and if they have secondary insurance I
will build their secondary insurance but
as Chris alluded to CMS is is doing the
mandatory National cost study and
they've determined that the cost of
providing the service is well below what
CMS is reimbursing and we hope to see
that change within the next four to five
years our next payer group those with
Medicaid and if you don't know anything
about New Hampshire Medicaid we get a
small stien from Medicaid for an EMS
transport that doesn't even cost the
cover of our response never mind the
transport so people with Medicaid have
zero financial
responsibility and then about 22% of our
residents have Commercial Insurance very
few that I'm aware of um entertain
participation agreements with insurance
companies Anthem is pretty strong in
this part of the state when I came on to
Dairy 15 years ago dery had a
participation agreement with Anthem and
when I looked at their rates they were
so low they were actually below Medicare
rates which is illegal I couldn't accept
those so myself with Town administrators
and Fire Chiefs went to Anthem in an
attempt to negotiate their rates they
refused to negotiate and they
essentially said good luck collecting
from our patients because we're not
going to pay you if you don't sign an
agreement and then we have about 14% of
patients who don't have insurance uh as
a result of the pandemic a lot of people
have lost their health insurance and
we've seen an increase in patients with
no health insurance and unfortunately if
we were forced into a participation
agreement the patient that would be left
with the largest bill would be the
patients with no insurance and that
makes no sense so I agree with Chris
staz and I'm in an opposition to this
bill I would like to look at the uh
Center for Medicaid services as they do
their National cost study and I think we
should use those numbers and I and I am
fully aware of the surprise billing
legislation is and we should probably
weigh into that here as well so the town
of Dair is opposed to House Bill 343
thank you very much
folks thank you very much any
questions okay uh chair will call in
Jeffrey
Spencer and I will promote you
Jeffrey be helpful hi my name is Jeff
Spencer and um I run a small company
called medical Business
Services um and I'll explain a little
bit why I'm here and why I've been
involved with this some folks probably
remember hearing from me last year I
will say that I am in Vermont not New
Hampshire although I uh spent you know
I'm not a carpet bagger uh I was I've
been well I've been an EMS since 1978 as
a provider um to this day was nationally
registered for 30 years so I've been out
there in the field um in um Vermont and
New Hampshire and then I became way back
in the Dark Ages and Assistant Attorney
General in New Hampshire so I was
involved with drafting legislation this
is back in the I always say in the Pam
smart era for those that remember it um
so as an Assistant Attorney General in
New Hampshire and then I was appointed
chief of fire standards and training in
New Hampshire also when we built the
fire academy um way back when
um so my background is is is as a
responder but also I am trained as a
lawyer although very much a lot of what
I do is not involved with the law I'm
not here as a lawyer at all um but say
as a matter back as a matter of
background about nine years ago um in
Vermont and New Hampshire working with
the my EMS folks you know I saw a need
for a billing company I credit our
billing
company it's more than a business though
I'll tell you that the reason I say that
is I'm in the thick of this all the
stuff you're talking about I deal with
every day we build 600,000 calls since
we we started um I do this stuff every
day I see what's going on in the
reimbursement world that's all I do um
so all these things you're talking about
I'm that's that's my life blood and as a
professional and as a person committed
to
EMS it's my legacy now you know I'm not
out there saving lives like I was when I
was 25 I'm not the chief of fire
standard training you know all I can do
right now is help the uh the EMS
community and the taxpayers they serve
on the reimbursement realm and that's
what we do
um
and a couple a couple of things so this
is all these things I deal with all the
time and I I'm committed to helping you
all and the positives are I do think
this problem can be solved I do think it
can be solved I don't think this bill I
think this bill starts and I know this
has gone on a long way but I think it
can be done and I do believe if
everybody knew the realities of EMS
which we've heard from Chris dewas um uh
we just heard from uh M Bohemian um if
you if everybody understood the
realities I think the solution would
become actually relatively clear I think
90% of the battle is is sort of getting
the realities of it um there's some
undeniable truths amongst and my my
customers are the the either nonprofit
corporations and there are a couple of
them nonprofits out there you know Tri
down ambulance down in uh in in pemr um
being one
and the municipal Services all of which
are taxpayer funded bottom line we're
talking about the taxpayers here in the
end this is all about the
taxpayers um for at least my segment of
that pie that um Justin was talking
about and I can tell you I know
everybody's rates I know all the rates I
know the rates Nationwide of them in
comparison every one of our customers
loses money on every call and that's why
they have to go to the taxpayers for
subsidies you know up in Plymouth um
that uh uh uh the representative fromp
up there that I've chatted with every
one of these Services loses money today
with their
reimbursement um and essentially any of
those losses get transferred to the
taxpayers it's a it's an undeniable
truth um that the rates that are charged
today do not cover
cost they're not too high I would I
would I would and I can support that
with data they are not
so if there's some belief that somehow
ambulance services at least in Vermont
and New Hampshire I can't speak for
Massachusetts and everywhere else are
just absolutely gouging people it's just
not the case um it's just not the
reality our rates are probably if
anything too low and as what um um Mr
heian said you know he is completely
right this is and and there was a talk
about cost shifts there's no cost
shifting in EMS there just isn't of all
of our customers just like what you miss
Mr heian say probably 50 to 60% are
Medicare patients those are the people
that call the ambulance retirement age
people fee schedule and the fee schedule
doesn't meet cost 10 to 20% is Medicaid
and Medicaid you know the Medicaid
reimbursement rate for a BLS emergency
is um $145 in the state of New Hampshire
it's um uh excuse $22.68 per mile
um and a BLS base rate is
$145. like I heard I think Mr heian
called that doesn't even Co cover the
cost to get the ambulance to the patient
and that right there that's you know 50
to 60% so there is no cost shifting
available like in a hospital where they
can get it from their MRIs you know
these these municipalities they're
running ambulance and that's it um and
uh I can't say that the truth of the
matter is the a lot of insurers out
there are using this model right now
they're repricing bills unilaterally and
you know the bill will come in for $800
and they'll say you know we think it
should be $600 and they'll pay 600 and
the patient ends up eating that and the
reality is um the reality is that it's
going to be that of the taxpayer there's
no cost shifting we talked about the
45th parall someone mentioned it great
example one of my longtime friends and
customers I think you may remember uh
hearing um from Nate he testified before
Val very eloquently their rates are
astronomically
high if anybody would look at it and the
insurance companies look at it and say
wow that's way too much but they're
serving providing Paramount level
service to and I remember his testimony
to an area the size of Rhode Island
their rates are really high and still he
has to go back and ask for an incredible
amount of money and I remember his what
he said from four of the poorest towns
in the state of New Hampshire the
reality is coming up with sort of this
let's look at what everybody else is
paying unfortunately as a methodology
isn't going to work and the reason why I
know people might think wait why come
they're not in the network it's exactly
there's no motivation to go to a place
like the 45th parallel the amount of
discounts that were required to join the
network made that situation even worse
so most these municipalities aren't in
network they simply can't afford to be
um because of the the rates allowed but
I guess I'd say there is a solution and
I know I am absolutely more than happy
to and I don't have a real stake in this
um I am just here because I think it's
the right thing to do and I'm concerned
about the future of EMS from a fiscal
standpoint um more than happy to uh uh
work with Mr Brennan um and also the
gentleman from the municipal Association
because I do think I I can see some some
sensitivity in this bill that there's a
there some there's a solution that
people are shooting for I think it can
be done um I do believe that the
methodology just when you step back and
look at
it if we want to
protect the taxpayers and we want to
protect the patient we have to somehow
find a way to make sure the payment rate
covers costs the C the reason for the
balance billing problem when it comes to
ambulance services and I'm going to only
speak for Vermont and New Hampshire is
because the rates are too low um and the
reimbursement rate is too low so the
taxpayers have to keep subsidizing that
operation and the answer to it is to get
the rates to be consistent with costs
and that's the solution um to that one
so I am imposed the bill in its form
although I think there's stuff that can
be done and I know probably people's
eyes are glazing over because you've
heard this issue um for so many years I
will stay to you as um a person that's
in the thick of this and I do believe I
sort of know my ranar around legislation
you this can be solved I just not quite
sure where they yet so thank you for
letting me
speak thank you um I don't see any
questions from the members so thank you
very much I now I now have three names
so I would say all these people didn't
sign up ahead of time but
um but I certainly not GNA send them
away so uh the next up is Jerry
Stringham and there you go uh thank you
um uh I'm Jerry stman I'm former State
Rep from Lincoln and Woodstock New
Hampshire uh it's nice to see many of
you again and
uh representative ham who uh currently
serves the area on the committee uh nice
to see you as well I was asked to
express concerns about HB 343 from
Lynwood ambulance to this committee
ambulance services in rural New
Hampshire a critical part of the health
structure and emergency response system
for our residents and also the out of
state visitors who enjoy enjoy the White
Mountains up here and often get involved
with rescues uh you know what I have to
say isn't isn't much different from what
you heard uh you know certainly we agree
that the Bill's goals of removing
balanced billing is laudable and uh
there's been considerable thought that's
going into its planning uh but rural
ambulance services like lywood ambulance
have concerns uh they feel they have no
no leverage over insurers uh in terms of
setting Fair rates uh they're generally
not under contract uh the rates uh will
not take into account the very high
Readiness costs in rural areas all
things you've heard uh and they are too
small a player uh for the insurance
commissioner to be of much help uh so um
the simple ask here is that the concerns
of critical services like Lynwood which
is you know really almost a central
element of uh of our Health Care system
in here be taken into account uh before
finalizing the bill and I know a lot of
uh a lot of good work has been done done
today um I know that uh David uh Tober
the uh Chief uh of lywood ambulance was
planning on listening in on this hearing
uh and probably be better uh to answer
any questions that you have uh but thank
you for this opportunity to speak and uh
for taking uh our concerns into
account fair enough thank you very
much all right two two left uh Justin
van
[Music]
eaten he's in limbo land right at the
moment Justin are you
there I saw a SC Square pop up for him
but he didn't nothing
happen I see a square and it doesn't
seem to be muted yeah it just just
it's he's there but not
there there he
goes I think he had
reboot and now you got to take your mute
off there you go there we go sorry about
that it was just I got the spinning
screen of death there for a moment um
thank you all for your time thank you Mr
chairman uh I will tell you that to the
best of my recollection it's been at
least a decade because my daughter was
born in the first one of the first
hearings I was involved in on this and
she just turned 10 uh so at least for my
involv I think you were chairing it back
then my name is Justin vanett and I live
in holderness New Hampshire I'm the head
of Stewart's ambulance which is one of
the largest ambulance services in the
state of New Hampshire we are also
headquartered in here in New Hampshire
and we have been for 40 years um I'm
just going to try and touch on a couple
of issues that people haven't mentioned
um first and foremost I will tell you we
as a company our corporate policy it's
been this way for three or four years we
do not balance bill for anything other
than co-pays and deductibles um we do
this because I live in the communities
we serve and it seems like every time we
sent out a balance bill they were a
friend of my mother-in-laws and I would
hear about it and I got lots of angry
people in my community so we went to our
towns uh in order to not balance Bill we
had to almost double what we charge UPF
front so we went to all of our towns we
we represent about nine towns and said
this is what we're going to do and so we
haven't balance build and and that has
worked out really well for us um we
would comply I was talking to
representative Weston and representative
Marsh about this you know we would
comply with this bill um which is a good
thing um but I have real concerns about
the power that this would hand to the
insurance companies um because one of
the problems as I understand it and
chairman you probably understand this
better than I do but insurance companies
are required to have a certain number of
primary care physicians or eye doctors
or orthopedic surgeons in every region
they don't have yeah they don't have to
have that for ambulance so they have
absolutely no motivation to uh contract
with us that's why nobody's in network
with them and you know I know from my
discussions because I also serve on the
board of Massachusetts as largest
Ambulance Company I would get paid the
exact same rate in downtown Boston that
I would in the northernmost reaches of
New Hampshire and it's that way because
again there are no requirements of
network adequacy uh on insurance plans
here in the state um the next thing and
part of that challenge uh Chris
mentioned this when it comes to cost
studies I work in urban areas in New
Hampshire and I work in very very rural
areas in New Hampshire in my very rural
areas I did the math yesterday it cost
me about
$1,100 every time I transport a patient
and urban areas it cost me between $3
and $400 every time I transport a
patient um and so there are huge swings
in my cost and every time I have seen an
insurance com uh a study out of the
insurance commissioner's office and
they've been great studies but they've
never focused on the cost of providing
this service and you've heard for 45th
parallel the costs are
stratospheric um so I say all of this
because I can certainly understand the
problem and challenge of balance billing
like I told you I live here so I've
gotten yelled at for many a balance bill
that we've sent out it's why we no
longer do it um but I think there has to
be some fairness because otherwise with
the insurance companies I suspect will
do is next year they'll pay me two and a
half percent less and am I really going
to appeal it is the insurance
commissioner going to support me and you
know it's it's a hard battle and then
the year after that it'll be 2.1% less
and then the year after that it'll be
1.6% less and it'll quickly make EMS in
New Hampshire uh simply not work it
barely works today so if you're going to
move forward with something like this
two suggestions that I would ask you to
consider is one it shouldn't be solely
the insurance commissioner's uh
prerogative there should also be a
representative from the commissioner of
safety uh because Mr romanello
understands that there's huge
differences in the cost of Readiness for
Rural communities versus urban
communities and I don't think that is
understood necessarily by the insurance
department they're wonderful people it's
just not what they do uh and secondly I
think you would have to put a provision
in a bill like this that requires
insurance companies to have some level
of adequacy throughout the state so that
they do have to have some sort of a
contract with people in The Lakes Region
and and you know in Coos County so that
right now when we negotiate with these
insurance companies it's all me sitting
there going you know please will you
give me and they don't care if you
required them to have a network they're
going to have to come to the table and
they're going to be motivated to to work
with us too so that's it it's a snowy
day I'll cut my comments off at that for
all of you but thank you all for your
time I greatly appreciate it yeah but
before I let you go you you really are
balance billing you're balance billing
the towns
not yeah that is absolutely true so the
the town it's a good point the towns
that cost me over $1,000 a call
like the Lakes Region towns where I live
they pay me annual subsidies of about
$600,000 a year so the taxpayers are
balance billing it in communities like
say summersworth which is a city with a
high degree of call volume um they have
the volume that like Manchester and
nashaa we don't charge summersworth a
subsidy they get that service for free
so you're absolutely right chairman
there is balance billing but it's the
taxpayers that get balance built right
thank you very much for your testimony
uh see no questions okay last last
person up David talber and I see that
you got yourself all ready and raring to
go uh thank you Mr chairman uh my name
is David tabber I am the chief of
Lynnwood ambulance in Lincoln and
Woodstock uh I thank the former
representative for speaking on our
behalf earlier I'm a 30-year resident of
Conway and used to work with Dr baros uh
providing EMS in the Conway area for
many many years um there is a huge
disparity
between uh the cost of service between
the various services in the state and
I'm I'm very concerned as the last
speaker said about simply the insurance
companies having all the power to set
the rates uh we are a volunteer
nonprofit service so we get a a small
small subsidy from the Two Towns we do
not balance bill um State residents uh
but we're also a huge tourist town and
when we pick up 130 40 people from the
two skas in our jurisdiction every year
uh and they happen to live out of state
we often collect nothing because the
insurance companies pay them pay the uh
policy owner and a policy owner Pockets
it and we have no uh way to go
go after them out of
state uh so there's a huge issue there
too when you talk about how we cost
shifting it's cost shifted onto our
volunteers um our volunteers who stand
by to respond to these calls um that and
and these huge Readiness costs of having
standby ambulances we have a 26 27 mile
oneway run to each of our hospitals it
makes for a two-hour run for our
volunteers round
trip uh a long dead leg where the
ambulance is out of service so we have
second and even a third ambulance here
in a town that really doesn't justify it
for the call volume because there's no
nearby Mutual Aid
geographically uh and and we don't have
the call volume to put in an AMR or a
service that's actually going to make
money by volume uh so we have huge
concerns with a bill like
this great thank you
uh any questions from committee
members see none we thank you very much
for your testimony I appreciate you
coming on and I have no more hands up so
I guess that's a good sign um and I know
you guys are all interested to hear
what's happened on the blue list so uh
there are a lot of names here and I I
would say chy they're all 603 so we
don't have to worry about out of state
people they're all on there there's a
handful of other Oddball um area codes
so that's that's the one way I get to
track to see if where they're really
calling from but or where they're where
they're coming from but uh the upshot is
there are uh 38 people in support 25
opposed and four neutral and that
is what blue sheet has um having no more
testimony we will close the public
hearing on House Bill 343
and that ends it for the
day okay um so uh any questions or
comments or anybody um want to reflect
before we we say goodbye and do this
again tomorrow and nine
o'clock uh yes representative abson yeah
Mr chair are we going to um break all of
these bills up into their various
subcommittees or are some just going to
be do you think well as I said before
we're really don't have time for
subcommittees um you we're not so at
this point uh unless the bill is just
needs a little tweaking here or there I
mean a bill like this I mean um the best
we can do is retain it and um and and
work on it come September um you know
that you in terms of we you you got to
vote either up or down or or we're
retaining and so any bill that's going
to need amendments or something I really
think we're g to just end up retaining
it fair enough so uh representative
burrow yes thank you just a house quick
housekeeping question just curious on um
Commerce do you ever Institute time
limits for people
testifying um I generally have said you
know myself I'm I I'm pretty good never
perfect I'm pretty good of scheduling
enough time so that we don't have a
problem um I would say there have been
times where I would say to people uh
please don't repeat the testimony that
we've already heard so if you got
something new to say great uh but that
you know and and that and I and and I
would say you know over my my many years
of being a chairman it usually time it
time it pretty closely I got it PR you
know pretty good but there have been
times where I've had to tell people to
to uh please be a model of brevity or
just submit written testimony but hasn't
thanks for that yeah yes representative
pus also uh in a lot of cases where we
have received testimony via email uh
when we have we were when we were in 302
a lot of the people who come in to
testify want to read the exact same
thing that we've already been emailed
and I know the chairman tries to push
them off from doing that
also right well I would say that um
another feature of the um of the card we
had was um the hum the person says how
much time they're going to have and I
would say this the sheet that I'm
getting uh it is there um it's a very
small print so but fortunately uh I have
biocal contact lenses so I can see and
and most people were you know say five
or two minutes or they just say zero
minutes and I know that that that ain't
true but uh but I I I would say whenever
I would see someone who put in a big
long you know 10 15 I would I would tell
them to cut it so are you all set max or
you just haven't taken your hand down or
do you have something else you want to
ask
me okay perfect okay we'll see you all
at n o'clock tomorrow morning thank you
byebye